[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
hey you caught me before i could even
smoke ladies and gentlemen i was getting
ready to smoke i forgot the show was
about to start
welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i am mark bernard
hey oh um
it is uh it is another fine
uh monday we don't generally do the show
on a monday um
i was back east so we couldn't do the
show saturday or sunday
but we didn't want to miss the precious
week of falcon
and the winter soldier so uh me and mark
talks about with jc and here we are
doing it
on monday and it's also later than we're
used to doing it so apologies to the
folks
over in the uk who are like you know
it's four in the [ __ ] morning mate
whatever um sorry it took us so long i
was preoccupied today doing a
motu masters of the universe thing all
day long because we're getting
ever closer next month mark people are
going to start seeing the first
images from revelation i know very
exciting i've seen the press kit
um other surprises that are stored like
we're
we're getting very very close so i was
working on that all day long today
and we couldn't start the show to hate
but the point is kids
the show has started and there is a
goddamn show mr mark garden
how are you and what you've been up to
i'm doing well man i think i think what
we're doing now instead of retraining
the audience to kind of return back to
the way the show used to be which was
tuesday nights at like eight o'clock and
so here we're on a monday
at like 8 30 and maybe next week maybe
week after we'll be back in the cantina
doing it live
and still beaming into the world and so
this is a nice
kind of reminder that the like weekends
at four
are probably going to begin to to peel
back
um i'm good man i'm good i uh i think
trying to think what i did the the last
time i saw godzilla versus kong
finally um which is ridiculous
so and you saw it in the theater right i
rented myself a theater and i sat there
with like
three friends and we saw godzilla v kong
in the movies uh quick question jc
bam finn here real quick i said quick
twice god i hate you
hello i always said quick once hello
jc uh just in case you don't have to
know for sure but
you know i can't on youtube i can smoke
weed to my heart's content but
facebook would do what to us i don't
know
that's a will wilkins will wilkins the
one time we were
you were smoking on stream was i got
like a flurry of text messages that was
like you can't
kevin can't facebook mark zuckerberg
which i understand there's a policy but
what would happen
like did they [ __ ] throw my account
off or yeah they might turn your account
off
we don't want that yeah but i had a real
tough day
anybody want to buy a fence
i feel like like this would be a much
cooler show
if i can just shake off the [ __ ] that
i'm carrying
i didn't get a chance to like you know
get centered before the show and stuff
and i'm just sitting here going like
i could be antsy about it or
i could ask the question which i've
never asked which is like what the [ __ ]
would facebook do
i mean mom i could turn your video off
and you can still talk well then well
now
but that goes against my ego like of
course
i don't want to not be seen and i think
to be fair
i might look cooler if i was smoking you
know people
in tv and movies they always look cooler
so
if i'm smoking i want to be seen jc but
you're just smoking clove cigarettes
it's not as if it's anything beyond that
that's true yes yes
for all yes of course it's just cloves
it's an actual cigarette every once in a
while like mark says
a man or woman um needs to
just kick back and smoke some clothes
oh will wilkins just wrote
will wilkins just hit us up breaking
news
he said they hold on it was on my screen
but now i gotta read it here
they threatened to shut your facebook
fan page down
for smoking clove cigarettes
i mean that's the thing right like
i mean all anybody can see is smoke and
will just
also said but if those are clove
cigarettes which they
are kids i'm not a big like uh
proponent i don't smoke tobacco and you
know
weed i'm not very familiar with but i do
enjoy smoking a good clove cigarette now
and then ladies and gentlemen
makes me feel like a trendy hipster so
once we get our program going here i'm
going to have me a clove cigarette but
before we get going
uh we have a sponsor we have two
sponsors tonight ladies and gentlemen
that's how lucky we are
um that's how blessed fat man beyond is
um and our first sponsor of the evening
ladies and gentlemen you know
you love them we love them because they
seem to love us because they keep
advertising on our show there must be
way less stinky people out there in the
world kids
because the good folks at native have
once again
chosen to uh to back
uh fat man beyond man like not and not
with like some kind words like oh i like
that show
by letting us advertise for their
wonderful brand
i was literally this is no [ __ ] i
was just in new york
and um i went into dwayne reed because i
was
picking up some mouthwash some listerine
and stuff
which sounds dirty when you say it like
that because instantly in my head i'm
thinking like
people are going like he was blown
people in new york wasn't he that's why
he needs listerine
no i'm just i have poor oral hygiene so
i always buy list stream wherever i go
so i went in to get some listerine and
mark
you know how unlike the the you know the
trial size
yeah like this is all the [ __ ] you could
put on the airplane and whatnot
little bottles and whatnot they had
beautiful baby native roll-on deodorants
like so cute man that you just like i i
like it would have made me feel a
hundred pounds heavier
if i used it because it was so small in
my tiny hands
off the molds of my arm and stuff but i
said
native has busted through man like
they're out there in the world when
you're in dwayne reed in the like 99
cents section of the small trial size
not 99 cents because nobody wants it and
[ __ ] but 99 cents because it's like you
need this to travel with
you have absolutely made it there they
are sitting right next to bottles of
listerine man native kids
is the deodorant that you need to be
putting all over your damn body man
like uh nativedeo.com fat man
go there right now as we talk about it
and as we're speaking
use their promo code fat man at check
out and get 20
off your first order that's
nativedeo.com
fat man or use the promo code fat man at
checkout for 20
off your first order mark tell us about
native yo
native formulated without aluminum
aluminium if you're in the uk
none of that british aluminium nuts soap
parabens or
talc it's vegan never tested on animals
it's made with ingredients you've heard
of like
coconut oil and shea butter you wear
deodorant every day shouldn't you be
able to understand the ingredients that
are in it
don't you want to know what's in your
pits native deo
is what that is that's like a real
philosophical question i've never
thought about that do i want to know
what's in my pitch you're absolutely
right
i'm not sticking in my pits here man
native deo
ladies and gentlemen dot com native
deodorant um
is something that not only uh is strong
enough for a man
but apparently made for a woman because
my wife took all my native products they
give us stuff in advance of doing an ad
so you could try it out so you can be
like well i do like this
or you could be like i don't want to do
an ad for these folks and i love
their deodorant i've talked about it
many times man i love that christmas
time they did candy cane
my old lady though snagged it all man
and then started buying it
in the real world like off of amazon and
stuff like that so
she became a believer and she's picky
and [ __ ] finicky
i mean i'm gonna date myself but she's
like that morris the cat from the 70s
man
just can't make her [ __ ] happy i
guess i can make a more current
reference than say garfield but even
that feels old at this point like mikey
with life cereals like
mikey likes us yes she's the mikey of
this [ __ ] house
you know i'm like hey jenny she likes it
but she does she loves
the deodorant as well man so like i i
stopped wearing deodorant at a certain
point i had a girlfriend like in the 90s
who was just like
that [ __ ] smells false you be you and so
i stopped wearing it but like
you know at a certain point you be
stinky you need to wear
something man native got you covered you
can put this stuff all over your body
like mark says it's vegan as [ __ ]
so you can like spread it on toast
if you want maybe maybe not but it's
vegan so you could do it
if you don't have time to run into
dwayne reed to give yourself some some
breath freshener put some [ __ ]
deodorant on your tongue your tongue
won't stink
right up and down man native uh
deodorant ladies and gentlemen proud
sponsor
of uh james up jane sub of uh fat man
beyond man there's no risk to try
native deodorant free shipping on every
order in the u.s
and native offers 30 day free returns
and exchanges
uh in the u.s what are you waiting for
man
i know you've been listening to us
talking about native for like a year now
like are you the last hold out are you
the only person that native wants us to
do an ad for
you sitting there watching this going
like i don't know
sounds promising but you know i hear a
lot of come ons from many deodorant
companies you're out of your mind
you're out of your mind kids you'll
never get a more pure offer
than you're getting right now as we tell
you right now to go to nativedeo.com
fat man make the switch to native today
by going to nativedeo.com fatman or use
the promo code
uh fat man at checkout you get 20
off your first order not only are you
gonna smell better you're gonna do it
for 20
less than than the average sucker pays
man you're ahead of the game because of
fat man beyond that's nativedeo.com
fat man or use the promo code fat man at
checkout for
20 off your first order native we thank
good folks and native for sponsoring fat
man beyond start thinking
stop stinking there's like he's a writer
they should take that
my madison acting is coming out we
created it on their
clock so that's worked for hire so you
can't even ask for more
money for it i i cannot it'd be silly
not to use that
um speaking of silly yes
godzilla versus khan
[Laughter]
let me tell you something my favorite
way to talk about
godzilla versus kong is when i smoke
clove cigarettes when it's going on so
you tell me
about the experience and i'm gonna sit
here and enjoy a fine clove cigarette
while you talk about that
um i i will say this uh godzilla versus
kong
is maybe the dumbest movie that i really
enjoyed
in the last year or so like it barely
holds together it doesn't make any sense
like things just kind of happen
i sort of described it as the like okay
what had happened was
movie where like i don't know there's no
connective tissue
it's okay so what had happened was like
kong was on this island right but it
wasn't an island it was actually like an
enclosure that they keep them on which
is on the same island but now there's a
roof
why don't know and so but what they need
to do is they need to go to the hollow
earth right why well because they need
to be there so
uh what had happened was they put them
on a boat how do you get caught on a
boat
don't ask these questions it's not that
important so kong is on a boat but
godzilla's after him because god
zilla's not the bad guy and oh by the
way billy bobby brown for stranger
things and like brian tyree you know
smith
and like they're like weird podcasters
slash teenager like they're the new doc
brown and marty mcfly for the 21st
century and they're just like
investigating [ __ ] for no good reason so
anyway godzilla is chasing after the
boat that has conor and then they fight
on
the boats because they're going to the
antarctic because they got to get to the
hole
through to the hollow earth right and so
what had happened was
um that's the whole movie like it's
literally just [ __ ] happening connected
maybe by boxcar
rail connectors but not by plot and or
character
um and the thing that was most
disappointing to me was
it's a movie made by legendary released
by warner brothers
which are the same people who made
pacific rim which
seemed to be a movie just waiting to
have godzilla in it but couldn't
for reasons called rights and so now you
get to like godzilla versus kang
and you get to mechagodzilla which seems
like the prototype for a jaeger and you
do not find a way
to synthesize this entire universe
together and just say like this is the
origin story of the [ __ ] jaeger
program
that like here's where it started
godzilla blasting a hole through the
earth with his radioactive
breath is how you open the rift that
lets monsters from the forbidden world
or the
the hollow earth kingdom into them like
all of these things could have been one
thing
but they were just apparently content to
make a really awesome punching
giant beast movie and an incredibly bad
human people talking movie and i've seen
it twice
[Laughter]
you rented a movie theater to do this
one of these dilettantes who were like
oh watch i'm a rich man i'll watch it on
hbo
max you actually went to the theater an
even richer man
went to the whole theater you got that
robert kirkman money i don't know about
man
i like white boy money is that what it
is
yeah look not in my world
um what happened when you went to see it
in the theater like is that the first
time you saw it there
yeah first time was there first time in
a theater in more than a year
when it washed over you did did being in
the theater and and the sentimentality
and nostalgia the
we're home again improve the movie did
that add to the experience
so much so like that and it was it was
less this
the the visuals it was more the sound
like kind of no matter what you do at
home
you cannot replicate you know 50
speakers in a room
just finely calibrated to deliver that
kind of experience
and a movie like godzilla versus kong is
built for just like
giant rumble and like you know sort of
spatial awareness with with the sound
it was great like it was it was a little
emotional like it was a little
like i remember this
this is when things were good i didn't
even like shitty movies were improved by
being here in the dark with the
strangers but there were no strangers
because i know
everybody right um yeah no it was it was
lovely uh i might do it again um
i don't know when i mean
definitely for dune if we're not back
just for real by november
i know somebody who saw dune and said it
was [ __ ] incredible
i said how long and they said over three
hours they said worth every second they
were like
it's unfucking believable um i'm not at
liberty to say who said it
because i'm not even sure if i should
say that they said it but
they you know i forget i oh you know
yeah somebody said that it was great
somebody in the know i know exactly who
said it but i just don't want to
help them in case though like you
[ __ ] idiot you're supposed to keep
that quiet
you know when i'll go i'll go for a
suicide squad that's that
yes to see starro on the big screen
excellent [ __ ] call
um i would say um this flick
like is probably the one flick
in recent memory that like delivered
exactly what it was supposed to be
yes you know if you don't like it that's
fine
but they literally gave us what
what we all came to see and they also
didn't make you wait
it's not like they were like we're gonna
wake you wait till the third act and
then
they give you a fight like pretty close
right up front in the first like felt
like half hour i felt like and it's like
90 minutes long like
means he gets in and gets out and gives
you two
really great kang v godzilla fights and
then you're like
i don't need more than this and we're
done roll credits
thanks very much and it's doing
incredibly well this is
i think it's the highest grossing movie
of the pandemic meaning like
worldwide they're almost at 500
million if you remember correctly which
is unfucking heard of in this moment in
time even the croods
which was the previous box office champ
i don't think has gotten there so
clearly if we were in a normal world
this would have been a billion dollar
grosser
minimum yeah but and to to
that point clearly the hbo max
experiment
didn't really wound this movie's
performances at the box office
was if you're still making 500 million
worldwide and
pirates have had their way with it um
since the minute it dropped
like that's not that's not a reason
for studios and streamers to find
themselves in at cross purposes
if you can just use this as marketing
for that
or have both they they have created
enough titan movies now
or at least brought enough titan
characters into these movies
where they could do like their own
[ __ ] monster hub
like [ __ ] channel man like just
it is porn if you love seeing
what some folks call kaiju or whatnot if
you love seeing giant monsters beat the
[ __ ] out of each other
like legendary's doing the lord's work
with that i mean to me it's
it's like the great irony is of course
you look at the origin material
and it's people in rubber suits you know
knocking over
many buildings now they have to spend
ungodly amounts of money
but it's so worth it when you like those
fight scenes are absolutely
[ __ ] incredible yeah no i mean the
best version of those is what we got
um which is uh which is saying something
given that we've had at least
three godzilla movies uh slash kong
movies
in the modern cg era um but so often
they just hid
[ __ ] at night like all right we're
fighting at night you can't really see
oh it's raining because raining is made
it's easier
and remember that remember that first
one they did where it was like you saw
godzilla
as the doors were closing you're like
like
it was like maybe like three minutes of
godzilla
in this like kong right up front yeah
right up front big first big fight
happens in the first half hour
like it's wonderfully made who was the
director as a kid who made uh
adam wingard who did the guest and
you're next
and the most recent um blair witch movie
is it was it a remake or something yeah
i think so like some distant sequel
well give him more based on thundercat
what is it he's doing thundercats next
oh he's the thundercats guy good yeah
give him all the money man clearly he
knew the tell story
with big characters with cgi um
and he he you know he everything was in
there that you wanted it to be there
you can't walk out of that movie and be
like well they coulda it was just like
they did it they literally did it and it
looked great
and hopefully they'll do it again yeah i
mean
again none of the human story made sense
every time a human person opened their
mouth it was nothing but exposition
um like literally i have no idea what
any of those characters wanted
to the point where i was like so you're
uh you're a podcaster who's trying to
um reveal the chicanery of this giant
corporation
and you're advertising on your podcast
that you're gonna go into work
and steal documents before you go into
work and steal those documents like
you're the dumbest [ __ ] conspiracy
theorist i've ever heard
declaring your intentions i'm going to
be a loss in this fool right now
come and stop me i dare you and then
they don't stop him
and they also drilled a hole from
florida to hong kong and nobody noticed
because just when you start falling into
like the logic trap of like what the
[ __ ]
suddenly is a giant lizard and you're
like we're back on track kids
um let me ask you this is this is what
occurred to me while watching the movie
other than like wow they're doing it
they're literally doing it they're just
beating the [ __ ] out of each other well
done
whenever human stuff kicks in even as a
child like you know
i don't give a [ __ ] about the human
story i just want to see the monsters
and [ __ ]
and i was chastised on twitter by
somebody who was like the human story is
the most important part of all this like
that's why these movies
are the movies that they are because it
was always meant as a commentary on
man's mastery over the atomic brothel
and so i get it i understand why the
humans are essential
that all being said i still would pay
double
to watch a 40-minute version of this
movie that got rid of
all the humans and just did like
you know what we want to see what we
come to see but
you know to put it in the parlance of
of 70s and 80s teenage kev
like i don't need the articles playboy i
just
you know we're page spread after four
page spread that's what i came here for
do you not want to know about the idea
is that not your thing no i don't need
the interview
um i i just want to see if nader has
some really interesting things to say in
this month's playboy interview
he can say him in newsweek i just want
to see
glory shots this is what occurred to me
while i was watching the movie
the people who play the people in these
movies the humans
like one of the easiest jobs in movies
man you're probably out in a week
like you're really in one place
talking about the threat there's very
rarely is the threat
interacting with you um i can't like as
somebody who makes flicks i'm like you
probably get shoot this person out
in a week like if they ever call you
kids to be in a godzilla movie just say
yes instantly
like doesn't matter what they're paying
you're going to be out in a week because
it's all about
the month and they're going to pay
pretty well you know like [ __ ]
alexander skarsgard and millie bobby
brown and brian tyree henry
and like lance redick who literally had
two lines
[ __ ] ain't cheap you know and
they just paid like their mortgage for
the year
yeah in in in like less time than most
actors
have to sit around on a cg movie or
something like that like go talk to
those avengers how
like they didn't get days off they're
[ __ ] always working and stuff
but on a king kong godzilla movie i bet
you get many days off as the human
if not they're just like trying to shoot
you out and get you the [ __ ] out of
there and stuff
yeah i mean it's possible to make a good
godzilla movie with a good human story
um there's there's a movie called shin
godzilla which came out i want to say
like five or six years ago
that's phenomenal like it's amazing i
remember seeing that
like a like a sort of double feature
that and chernobyl are very much the
same story
which is here's ungodly you know sort of
natural disaster
made compoundly worse which is not a
phrase
um but by the inefficiency of human
bureaucracy
like it is it's a story about red tape
and how red tape ultimately lets
godzilla just run rampant
throughout japan and you're with this
one salary man who's doing his best to
convince people
like guys if you just listen to me we
can stop everything and nobody will
and watching people sort of pass the
buck and just shift it down the line
while godzilla's
metastasizing and evolving it's
heartbreaking because you know that's
exactly what would have happened
if godzilla hits modern japan in the
same way that chernobyl is
if one dude just does the right thing
and says hey maybe we should
look at these safety parameters you
don't lose the lives of hundreds of
thousands of people
and you know just watch a government
implode upon itself
it's it's fascinating that said
i could 100 deal with the just the
punchy cut
of this movie that's 45 minutes long
that is just cg punching cg for a while
i don't need more of this story i think
that would not be compoundly worse
that would be compoundedly better
coins
[Laughter]
you know how like siskel and ebert had
thumbs up thumbs down
we can have like our catch phrases
and you know mine is probably gonna be
like it's awesome because i like
everything
yours can be like compoundly worst
[Laughter]
there's your next t-shirt never mind
[ __ ] what is it
um
what does that mean i'm unclear on that
but i made it up
you went to a movie theater to watch
this movie god bless you
yes um and we'll probably
should be buried in the news but since
it's happening right now
this may not matter to the rest of the
world but here in los
angeles ladies and gentlemen they just
announced a few hours ago
that the cinerama dome and the arclight
cinemas
the arclight being the premier
uh exhibition uh cinematic exhibition
anywhere shy of maybe the best place you
can ever see a movie
both in picture quality and sound is in
the stag screening room
at skywalker ranch um
the next best place you can watch movies
was always at an arclight man
picture perfect presentation sound
quality was incredible
black box theater no distractions they
had
ushers come in and introduce the film
and whatnot
it was a fantastic experience and they
just announced that
that experience is over for good they're
closing
the arclight and the cinerama dome now
cinerama dome will probably
go to some other company and will reopen
because it's an
icon they're not getting rid of it it's
not like they're going to knock it down
for [ __ ] condos or something they
actually can't because it's a historic
site
exactly so it'll the cinerama dome will
be back
question mark right now is
what happens to the arclight like you
know it's bad enough we're all dealing
with the heartbreak of the arc like
going away forever
but you know the first question is well
who's going to buy it and
if the arc light's going away that's an
indication that the business is not
strong enough to support one of the
strongest
exhibitors in in the west coast
marketplace
so would somebody else be able to fill
that void
who the [ __ ] could buy the arc light and
run it
and if they did that i i was just going
to say
that you know the there's a hundred
percent a section of the business
that is both yearning for legitimacy and
has
nothing but money to spend and it's
probably somebody like amazon or netflix
i thought you were gonna say the porn
community you're right they've been
waiting for their moment
like this theater this is legitimacy
um you're right you're absolutely right
it could be something like well netflix
bought the
uh the egyptian theater out here
so they're in the theater buying
business yeah and so they would get
they would get you know the the three or
four southern california locations
plus the location that's in new york and
i think there was one they just opened
in chicago perhaps and so it wasn't just
here
and it wasn't it's not like a vast
proliferation of a chain
but it's enough to be like hey you know
what like if we're gonna own the best
theaters in the world
we can do that and they can keep the
name too it could be the alliterative
amazon's arclight man
yeah but you know and i think that like
the movie businesses
is on its way back i think once the
vaccination levels continue to rise and
once people begin to feel comfortable
leaving the house clearly godzilla
versus kang is showing that like
worldwide was was huge but even
domestically the movie made something
like 50 million dollars
since it's since its release which is
nothing to sneeze at
and so it's coming back but a year of
not being able to admit people
just had companies in the red in and to
a degree that they could not
come back from it you know i think what
was it they're
there let me see but the culvert city
location
um owed as much as 181 000
um due in full to the collections agency
and it's hard to imagine a theater being
able to make that much money back
to be able to reopen let alone to just
carry that debt and slowly chip it down
like it's it's uh it's a lot to shoulder
that
that's less than scum and villainy o's
by the way
in rent the arclight movie theater owes
less in rent in culver city than scum
and villainy owns
oaths in background are you kidding me
is that how much
rent you guys are supposed like what
12 uh yeah 12 months of rent
quarter million bucks
what's wrong with these guys yeah if you
can make it work how come the arc lights
folding
uh probably because our landlords
haven't pushed on us yet
um or they're just like
it's not worth the fight for them
they'll just fold arclight they'll open
a new company
called arclight 2 and then just get it
at
covet rent prices because they probably
were on a lease
that was way more expensive when the
economy was more up
but yeah it's it's rough out there
unless you're a landlord
and then business is good yeah so and
it's not just dark light it's also
pacific theaters
which was a larger more sort of
widespread chain to specific closing
pacific owned arc light did they really
the people that own the grove
yeah wow so the grove is going down
so both the pacific at the grove the
the theater and all the arclight
theaters are closing
yeah now i mean somebody will swoop in
to some of these high traffic air like
the hollywood arc light will reopen as a
theater at some point probably within
the next six months
um because somebody will say there's
money to be made here there was might it
was the highest grossing of the arclight
locations
we can make a thing happen here somebody
will move into the into the cinerama
dome and make that work
somebody will move a theater and move
the theater into the grove and make that
work
but it won't be arc light necessarily
some of the other arclight locations
will probably fade away or
show up in some other iteration but it's
it is huge for
la and southern california movie going
um and a bellwether
you know especially after the draft
house the alamo drafthouse declared
bankruptcy
and they still haven't yet sort of
declared at least in l.a when their
theater is going to reopen
so it's it's it's rough out there for
specialty movie theaters
chains can can handle it you know amc is
coming back
cinemark is coming back um but yeah man
it's a it's a very tenuous time
um it is uh it's a bummer
because i saw uh many many wonderful
movie experiences i had
uh in the arc like they built a new
model and a lot of people copied that
model around the world and stuff but
they were kind of first out the gate to
do what they did
um i would say uh
you know i wasn't prepared for them to
go away forever
i thought they'd be back as soon as we
opened up and whatnot but for everything
they ever did
for me and mine i took my kid you know
i've lived out here for
since the theater open i was there the
first week that the arclight opened up
so most of the movies i took my kid to
see i took her to see
at the arclight and whatnot and so you
know it's a whole section
of not just my life but her life too
that's
kind of gonna now go away and stuff but
we have the wonderful memories of the
movies we saw there and all the time we
spent there so
to the good folks at arc like and
pacific because i enjoyed going to the
grove as well
um we offer our condolences and we also
give you a a historical jeff's kiss
unbelievable can't believe we were we we
will see the end of the arc light in our
lifetime that's nuts i thought it would
outlive
at least me maybe not you but
[Applause]
um all right all right all that bad news
mark we should get
to the good news and the good news
always comes in the way
lately of one of these disney plus shows
they crushed it
with wanda vision marvel and now marvel
is crushing it again
with the fourth episode of falcon and
the winter soldier
in which we ended with
one of uh the most brutal
iconic memorable images marvel has ever
committed
to their screens spoilers kids if you
haven't seen it yet but come on it's
monday how the [ __ ] have you not seen
what the [ __ ] were you doing with your
weekend
other than watching falcon in the winter
soldier um
john walker captain america
holding the bloody shield the very
shield
that he used to kill a man who just
earlier had talked about what
captain america meant to him was a
game-changing moment that made me
think one of two things is gonna happen
if it's anything like the comics
eventually sam will be like you know
what i am captain america and we get a
new captain america in the way of sam
but right now man that shield is so
tainted
there's a chance where they're just like
look
we're getting rid of this like we had
captain america and he'll always live in
our hearts but
going forward he's not going to be a
part of this marvel matrix
do you think that's possible
um i don't but
i i i think it'll be more of a struggle
than it might have been before
for sam you know like and it's the thing
that i'm that i'm
that i've been longing for especially in
this episode which i like this episode
this episode does a lot of really fun
things
a lot of interesting things um but i'm i
keep
longing for sam specifically to have
more of a thrust and a drive than he
does now which just seems to be
i gotta find these flag smasher people
you know and like
and zemo should probably go back to jail
that'd be cool
right you know like i i kind of want him
to be slightly more engaged
with what seemed to be the core of the
show
which was can a black man be captain
america
and he doesn't seem preoccupied with
that at all
um other characters are like there's
there's lots of like when you talk to
his sister
when carly calls her sister and she's
like you know does does
you know how do you feel about captain
america she's like my world doesn't
matter to america why should i care
about its mascot
you know and i'm like that's yeah like
let's talk about that let's talk about
you know what the government does
to black and brown people in the in the
name of
america you know and we see the
sacrifice of uh of battlestar
you know which is which is horrific to
watch
but it's like okay it's just another
black dude sort of cut down in service
of
a a a mission and a quest that is not
his
you know the desire for super soldier
the desire for power the desire for all
of that like
the people who usually fall by the
wayside don't look like john walker
and so engaging with stuff like that on
the perimeter is really fascinating
but it's what does sam and bucky want
and how does it
relate to the main threat and the main
quest
i'm still squishy on you know like i'm
here for the door i'm alive
[ __ ] just like showing people some [ __ ]
and like you know the very definition of
[ __ ] around and find out is go ahead and
touch a door on the shoulder
and see what happens captain america
um but yeah no i'm i'm i'm here for it
but i'm i'm starting to get a little
impatient with it and that's weird to
say given that we're four
four episodes into a six episode run
yeah there's only two left at this point
there's only two left that's why i'm
wondering if like you know even if
you're doing our piece for those
episodes that's two hours for sam to be
like you know what
i am captain america there's a chance
that you don't
pick up the shield or the outfit by the
end of this show um
once again they're doing a good job of
keeping us guessing
um i loved this episode
uh because it was baron zemo being baron
zemo like you know he
like he's deceptive as [ __ ] he
engineered
another civil war essentially and then
[ __ ] ducked out into the bathroom and
hid in the sewer like he's fast becoming
my favorite
marvel villain in the marvel cinematic
universe like
and because they get to spend more time
with him than generally they get to
spend with most villains
you know in most movies you meet the
villain and find out their arc and then
they
beat the villain and then they're gone
but here we get to
hang out with zemo for a while i'm
liking
this zemo so much like it didn't bother
me that he didn't put the mask on this
week
you know watch now now it's just you
know it's baron watch i'll just watch
him be the bearer and himself you don't
even have to pull on the [ __ ]
mask i saw an interesting theory on
twitter somebody said
under that mask is
a flag smasher mask
because they were like when he picked it
up from the car it had a form to it that
kind of resembled
the flag smasher form i was like that's
very interesting i never would have
connected those two
but uh rule is daniel bruhl is just
[ __ ]
killing it man like just chewing the
scenery living his best life being
[ __ ] baron's emo
yeah and you know the most evil thing he
did this week was try to convince people
that turkish delight is a candy you
should eat
and that [ __ ] is just like chewing on
petroleum like it's the worst
i'm sorry people who like turkish
delight but it'll just pull your [ __ ]
molars out
it's like come here kid would you like
some of the worst candy ever made
tell me your secrets i don't want to
come off as like an ugly american but it
just always occurs to me as like
a far far eastern european candy where
it's like they don't
they don't know how good a kitkat is or
like if you think this is candy it's
like oh
come here let me fill you with diabetes
it's like a candy made from people who
didn't have easy access to sugar
and you see the kids scrambling for the
snacks it's like kids if you think this
shit's good
oh my god get out of the peep over here
you got heaps of the worst [ __ ] candy
ever but that's light years better than
turkish delight
how creepy was it hearing him sing baba
black sheep
yeah better however than ring around the
boat rosie which is the darkest [ __ ]
nursery rhyme excellent point um anthony
maggie is still doing a wonderful job
even though
like you said perhaps he could use a
little more motivation i don't bump into
that at all you know me i'm just like
it's all [ __ ] good and it really was
this time around like episode
three episode one and two gigantic
[ __ ] off we're all fighting on a truck
or we're fighting in helicopters
action sequences three a lot of close-in
fighting action but not big expensive
action sequences a lot of fight scenes
if sam didn't put the wings on
in three this is the first episode that
sam puts the wings on
since two um but did you notice how
limited it was
he didn't do much flying no he went up
and then he crashes through a window but
that was about he uses the jet to fire
out one of the enemies and [ __ ]
but you could see the like you know we
gotta start big man
spend all that money up front then
four you know three and four just you
know
keeping keeping daredevil good
five and six we're gonna blow the roof
off this bad boy like you can tell it's
escalating yet again
but you can it was i was glad that he
put the wings back on because i was like
all right
yeah i also my favorite moment i think
was the look on the astonishment on
bucky's face
when the dora did the [ __ ] cheat code
on his arm
and he's like but this was mine
look not really this was a lease at best
and we can always take it back when we
want you know he had the look on his
face
when [ __ ] uh you know the bride did
the [ __ ]
finger punch into his heart you know and
kill bill and [ __ ] where he was like
what the that's a thing you could do
that i loved my [ __ ] he was like did
you know they could do that he was like
no and he put him on and he did that
terminator thing where he like ratchets
it back
and [ __ ] like that it was so [ __ ]
cool sebastian stan
uh doing a wonderful job man like uh
still finding cool ways to play it and i
loved
that they took him back to wakanda then
we got
like you know i felt that was you know i
know it's they're in tight and around
fire and stuff like that but i was like
that's money man like [ __ ] bringing
money not just money it costs money to
shoot the scene but also
like money that they're like bringing
wakanda into it and we knew they were
about to based on the
final scene from episode three um but as
you said before we got to see
you know uh the the dora how do you say
it again
um in action um fighting uh
captain america and and battle star um
and and uh and also uh you know bucky
and and falcon as well yeah and and
three women just destroyed four
superheroes
and they didn't even have the super
powers
sounded like a broken child like they
weren't even super soldiers
maybe i'm the worst captain america ever
uh sharon carter pops in to remind us
that she's totally the power broker
yes yeah yes that's what it's starting
to feel like right
i mean it's only because you know let's
pretend this is a [ __ ]
procedural show the bad guy you've met
the bad guy before
you revealed it to be the bad guy like
it's either gotta be zemo or sharon it's
not gonna be some dude we've
never met before right so like
kinda probably yeah
yeah especially once like there's a line
where she she tells sam that she's gonna
task a satellite she still has access to
a couple of satellites
and then carly somehow knows that that
sam's sister
like has a boat that's on a dock and
like
well how would she know that unless
somebody's feeding her satellite footage
of where sand
lives and who's got access to a
satellite huh
i wonder um carly
uh morgenthau is that how they're doing
um i had a really good scene with uh
with
anthony mackie where you know they were
kind of like all right let's let's
have the talk and then all of a sudden
[ __ ] captain america busts in and
ruined [ __ ] and whatnot
um that was a really good scene i like
that actress i think she's doing a great
job
yeah now she was really good she i
remember seeing her in solo
she was the emphasis nest in solo
oh yeah i didn't put that together
yeah i like her she's doing a great job
um and uh what's his name uh
uh uh why is it wyatt russell
yes um kurt's boy great job at making
you despise
[ __ ] john walker captain america and
for no good reason not like you know
he's a [ __ ] villain although at the
end of this episode we saw his true
colors um
battle star lamar made reference to it
uh calling back the words of erskine by
saying like well the
the you know the serum just makes you
more
of what's already there you know but it
was also the kind of jimmy cricket on
on john walker's shoulder being like
look
you're the guy that [ __ ] did this and
did this you know what to do
in the heat of battle without super
soldier serum
you know like reminding him like you
don't need that [ __ ] like you
you got this [ __ ] shield and this
helmet not because they pumped you full
of juice but because like
in the field you were this that or the
other thing and you could tell
like you know they're building toward
like he's it ain't going to be enough
for him
well and then him getting his ass kicked
by the wakandans which was awesome
led him to that place of like i'll never
be powerful enough and so when
zemo smashes all the super soldier
serums which is like completely on brand
and absolutely in character
um that one off to the side like as soon
as he comes running into the room i was
like
no as soon as he picked it up i was like
yes yes
they're doing it they're going full
usage it's
uh you know i i've been reading that the
poor kid
uh [ __ ] goldie hawn's kid why uh kurt
russell's kid
they're beating them up because he's
doing such a good job people like i
[ __ ] hate him
but they hate the character but he's
getting the [ __ ] hate for it
it's like they forgot how acting works
suddenly it's like did you forget the
last like 100 years of drama where like
a dude is playing another person and
it's not his actual
thing and it's like it's like what so
[ __ ]
josh roland just gets away with it
because he don't look
like he does in real life because he
looked like thanos and [ __ ]
so weird that they're like i hate this
guy it's like well yeah you're supposed
to maybe
i don't know about hate him but he's
he's not the good guy and
and you're welcome to feel like he ain't
my [ __ ] captain america that's kind
of the point of the story and [ __ ] but
like
hating the actor for [ __ ] playing the
part it's like he didn't even write it
the dude was just like look i'm just
doing the lines they want me to do blame
kevin feige for heaven's sake
but you must be good at your job man
it's a high praise if like people are
like literally hating on your ass
yeah i mean i hope that for him you know
i remember
reading the stories of the actor who
played james gum
in sons of the lambs who like forever
and
always was james gum whenever he would
go out into the world like a
buffalo bill said no i'm just an actor
man i was on psych for like eight years
is like
just a regular police captain i'm just a
guy like
nah man you [ __ ] both no no no it
puts the lotion on its skin
and puts it in the basket or it gets the
hose again he's like oh
god damn it i'd [ __ ] me no all i want is
a big mac
dude
so yes i wyatt i hope i hope that people
remember how how sort of performance
works
and leave that boy alone yeah don't jam
gum this guy for having sex
don't just because a guy in a movie is
like oh wait is she a great big fat
person doesn't mean you get to hate him
in real life
he got paid to say those words yes
handsomely
two episodes left where is this [ __ ]
going mark uh
well uh i don't know um i'm hoping that
because the the thing we should be
feeling by this episode and granted
this is the according to hoyle kind of
structural
math of story this should be sam
and bucky's lowest moment right like
we're we're four episodes of six we're
at the end of the second act
all should feel lost and it doesn't so
it seems as if they've got to lose
something major
next episode and then find a way to kind
of
claim it back by the finale whether that
looks like
um sam keeping the shield finally
whether it looks like sam returned the
shield to wakanda
which it seemed as if the dora 100 could
have done that if they wanted to
we could have walked out instead she was
like leave it yes we don't need that
it's tainted they painted it funny
we don't want it this color yeah color
is terrible
um you know i you know everybody sort of
wants him to want the shield um and to
want it for the right reasons not just
because
it'll end up in the hands of the wrong
captain america but because he might
have the chance to be the right captain
america
and so it feels as if the last two
episodes need to get sam to a place
where he believes that
um or he believes that he can do the
right thing and he can do more of the
right thing by holding the shield than
he can without it
i mean i like it's they're so good at
their storytelling
and as much as like they have stopped
just doing sequels and they've started
just world building like crazy
whereas you know at the end of [ __ ]
uh spider-man
far from home i'm like oh yeah he's
gonna go to high school next year the
prom is probably a thing and everything
and then all of a sudden they're like
[ __ ] no his secret's out and
everything's [ __ ] different
um even with end game you know we wipe
out half the planet then we bring them
back but now in these shows it's like we
show you perhaps
you know there's difficulties regarding
that they're not afraid to like
move the ball down the field like
they're not holding on to past glory and
[ __ ] like that
so i don't know like i watched the last
scene of this episode and him holding
that bloody shield i was like
is it that's a very graphic image
like you know and and one that will be
kind of burned in our
memory for a long time to come is this
their way of just being like
we're moving away from that like the
shield ain't gonna be a part of this
thing anymore they're like hey
tony stark ain't a part of this thing
anymore so maybe the shield ain't a part
of this thing anymore
and you know we're all we all assume
that because it's marvel and because
it's cap
and because the shield and you know it's
like oh they'll never get rid of that
but they have shown a willingness to
upend the universe to tell their story
push it further like it's not about what
comforts us
it's all about like look we're gonna
tell this story and we're going to go in
this direction in this direction
so you know i ain't calling it i don't
know for a fact but as i watched that
last scene i was like
this may be them distancing themselves
from it
for good because that's a tough image to
[ __ ] erase
like it's gonna take more than two
episodes
to erase that bloody shield from not
just you know the
minds of the folks within the world as
we saw a bunch of people taking pictures
and stuff like that
but just the marvel fan base as well
they're really
going out of their way to make us think
about this symbol
and i i wonder if in the next two
episodes they're just gonna be like
shield's gone they could always bring it
back somewhere down the road
but i think we're all expecting like
because they did it in the comics
that sam will just become the new
captain america but maybe this is about
how there is no new captain america
maybe you know it's like that happened
once it was special just like somebody
just like [ __ ] uh uh zemo that he was
talking about like people get this [ __ ]
and [ __ ]
it turns them into you know monsters and
stuff and they're like but not steve
rogers and he was like touche
like maybe the point is there won't ever
be another steve rogers and
does you know sam even need to be
captain america he's the [ __ ] falcon
he's got his own thing going on and
maybe the idea is as they show the
tainted legacy and now
like the shield what it stands for is
not what it used to stand for now
there's a image of that shield that's
going to be very hard
to erase from the public consciousness
perhaps they just leave it
behind and just move forward telling
different stories
like i i hope you're right i hope you're
right for for one
for lots of reasons because i think
that's great story and great fodder for
more story going forward
but it would be surprising and i think
that the thing that i've been missing in
the last couple of episodes
is legit surprise it's like i
knew that john walker was gonna go dark
like they they've been telecast
you know forecasting that since the very
beginning i knew zemo was gonna betray
them because he's [ __ ] zemo and
that's what he's gonna do
you know i i knew that sam would not be
able to talk carly down because
john would do something stupid like
there's these things that you can kind
of see coming down the
down the road that like yeah no i get it
i understand it but give me the thing
that i didn't see coming
and nobody being captain america is not
the thing that i saw
coming like i saw somebody figuring it
out you know be it that sam decides to
do it against his better judgment
be it you know the government decides
like fine okay it can be bucky because
sam doesn't want it
um i i'm not sure but something that we
can't see coming a mile
a hundred miles away would be
fascinating and so i hope you're right
spider-man in chat spider-men said
you've watched too much snyder that's
way too cynical
they'll redeem it this is a cat that's
like
don't [ __ ] with the shield man like
that's dark
don't bring it back they're going to
clean it up they'll get the blood off
that shield don't you worry
um a stark image you know as a
storyteller
i was both thrilled and jealous where
i'm like that never would have occurred
to me
what a powerful and shot low too
that high hero angle up at him and he
just cuffed you know just as per usual
took the shield and
put it right on his arm and just [ __ ]
stood there like ooh
some dark [ __ ] man dark mutant people
keep pointing out in chat though
that hey i saw on the trailer that sam
and bucky at one point have the shield
like we've seen him throw the shield in
many of the trailers
doesn't necessarily mean that he becomes
captain america
um some other chad have suggested that
they
melt the shield like hylo sir here says
melt the shield
turn half into a new arm for bucky and
then the other half into new wings for
falcon which is a really interesting
idea i doubt they're going to do that
but that's not
dark as that other guy said like hey man
that's
that's kind of snyder hopeful right
there um
well i mean i think in in talking about
things that are surprising talking about
the desire for story we couldn't see
coming it is worth uh talking about the
origin of the winter soldier himself
because nobody could have seen
that coming given that bucky had been
dead and like dead dead dead like dead
for real dead
um but there was one comic book writer
who thought to himself
but what if he's not dead um and we just
happen to be lucky enough to have that
gentleman
as our guest surprise guest on tonight's
podcast welcome aboard mr ed brubaker
hey ed
don't meet yourself oh put your take
yourself off mute my friend
i'm so embarrassed i've been i've been
i'll be you've
been in the club cigarette mode for a
while
aren't we all kids nothing wrong with a
clove cigarette now and then
i was here on clove cigarette night and
i enjoy it
um ed the uh we'll talk about
uh winter soldier in a second um but
even if whether you're watching the show
or not watching the show
at the moment me and mark obviously
obsessively watch every episode
as a driver yeah you are you must be
familiar
with the fact that this week disney plus
released
a one hour like comp compilation of
baron zemo dancing
not since the snyder cut has an audience
demanded something and
gotten it that [ __ ] quickly this took
even quicker than the snyder cut
a bunch of fans yeah daniel bruhl had
done an interview where he was like um
you know we did a lot of dancing there's
like an hour of me dancing a lot of
takes and stuff
and so fans were like we demand the
[ __ ] zemo cut
oh i saw that people were i was like
what was that
they delivered it they delivered a
one-hour like
cut of him dancing and it was a lot of
repetitive shots and [ __ ] but you could
sit there
and watch it over and over again like i
appreciated as a fan
how they leaned into it where they were
like what do the fans want [ __ ] give
them an hour zemo dance party
yeah no that's amazing yeah listening to
you guys talk about the show was kind of
amazing because i haven't been
keeping up with it and i'm listening to
you guys and i'm like it sounds really
good
it sounds like they're doing a really
good job how do you not
keep up for me that would be like well
my daughter harley
you know once she went to work on so i
just stopped paying attention to her
how do you watch your kid head into a
another medium because because winter
soldier is your
kid there was no winter soldier before
you
do here let's take it to this moment
before we talk about what's it feel like
to watch that
do you remember the moment you came up
with the name
oh yeah yeah well i mean there's the
whole
bucky thing is crazy for me i was like
bucky was always my favorite character
because i was a military
brat just like bucky like i i my dad was
in naval intelligence and i was born in
the
bethesda naval hospital and lived in
virginia near
like the cia headquarters and then
started school
in gitmo actually uh which was like
you know there's like three
neighborhoods of officers families that
live in gitmo
and that's where i discovered like comic
books
you live you lived at gitmo yeah i mean
before
it was before 9 11 gitmo was just a
naval base
or like it like in uh like a few good
men they
yeah exactly you need me on that wall
yeah
you can't handle the truth um yeah no i
lived in yeah i lived on radio point
which was
where the naval officers families lived
and there was another place where the
marine officers families lived
and i was i started school there we
moved we lived there from like
age four to like age seven for me
and i would just walk down the hill to
the px and buy comics
and i thought i was buying like this
week's comics not realizing that when
you live on the px
like whatever you're seeing like i would
wake up and turn on the tv
and it would be charlie chaplin and
buster keaton i would think oh these
guys are amazing
72. like i thought that was
and that's where i saw like the marvel
cartoons
and i i think i saw the captain america
marvel cartoon from the 60s where it's
just
adapted from the comics that america
froze is mighty
yeah exactly and so but there's that
scene where bucky is like the navy
the military brat who discovers that
steve rogers is captain america he's
like oh you gotta make me your sidekick
and so bucky was always my favorite
character because
i was in need i was a navy brat and it
just seemed like
you know i just had that connection with
them of like
being part of the military as a kid and
so when i started buying comics
like i'd go to the px and they would
have comics from like five years earlier
so like one of the first comics i ever
bought with my own money was
the um there's a there's a it's cap
156 i think where it's like the captain
america from the 50s he's got his own
crazy bucky they like pre-date john
walker basically they were like the
um they they took the super soldier
serum and they got
facial changes it was all just a big
retcon
to explain why captain american bucky
was stealing comics in the 50s and
but it was like these two captain
americas fighting on the cover
and one was the real steve rogers and
one was this guy who was like his
biggest fan
who just like went twisted and you know
became like a racist
and it was like it was just really
intense story to be reading at like age
five
and um so like as a kid though
like i had every issue of captain
america that i could get and it started
at issue 100 like the marvel ones did
and so i for some reason assumed
that back during world war ii when they
were publishing it they did
issues 1 through 99 and in issue 99
bucky got blown up by zemo like i
thought there was a real comic for that
and when we moved to san diego when i
was like seven
i went to comic-con this is like the
early 70s mid 70s when it was still at
the el cortez hotel
and i remember walking around the
dealer's floor this is what it was like
just dealers and comic book people
and like jim sturranko and bob keane
would be giving like
lectures about how to draw batman or
captain america or whatever
um and i i looked at all these dealer
stables i was looking for issue 99 of
captain america because i wanted to get
the issue where bucky died
because i had read all these you know
avengers issues i've read all these
modern captain america issues where cap
where steve is always remembering how
bucky died and i was like i want that
actual issue because i had the issue
where glenn stacy died
i had a reprint of the issue where uncle
ben died these were all things that
really happened
and i remember asking this dealer when
he saw that i was getting disappointed
when i was looking through the captain
america's actually like what are you
looking for i'm like
i want issue 99 where bucky dies
and this guy just started laughing at me
i was like a eight-year-old or
nine-year-old kid
and he's like kid there's no issue 99
stan lee just didn't want to have a
sidekick so he got rid of him
and jack kirby was like cool whatever
and and i was like
they can't do that i was following that
story
yeah i was like this is [ __ ] my
whole life is predicated on this being
canon
and so i as like even at age nine or ten
i started thinking about that i thought
well if i ever get a chance to write
this comic i'm bringing this character
back because
as far as i'm concerned it didn't happen
in the comic i i can
change and so it was like a thing i
thought about
on and off throughout my whole life
because i was always like writing and
drawing my own comics as a kid
and then um when i actually started
doing comics i
totally gotten away from superhero
comics and was doing like independent
comics
and uh you know you and i both would
work with bob schreck in the 90s
yeah that's you know bob was one of the
people who gave me my first break and
brought me in to work on batman
when he was over there and you were
working on batman stuff through him too
but um i had moved away from that until
i
realized hey i actually like to make a
living
and then i went back and started reading
like what people were doing in the
industry i'm like oh comics
even superhero comics have completely
evolved post watchmen
into these really kind of interesting
long drawn out stories
um and so i was doing a bunch of stuff
at dc
and brian bendis was one of my oldest
friends we started out in independent
comics together
and he was you know doing everything at
marvel and he called me up and he knew
my dc contract had expired
and he said what do you want to do at
marvel and i said well the only two
characters i would really want to do
is is iron fist and captain america and
i know they just hired someone new in
captain america so i've never
you know i'm never going to get that job
he's like oh actually they fired that
guy and they're looking for someone
and that's what they want you that's
what they want to offer you
and i and i was like oh well they're
never going to do what i want to do with
it and he's like what do you want to do
i'm like i want to bring bucky back as
like a bad guy
and you know make it like a big tragedy
and he's like well conveniently
we just had a summit two weeks ago where
axel and joe
and tom brevord all screamed at each
other about bringing bucky back
and so they're totally open to it
and he's like so you know it's all about
like what pitch you've got for it
and then joe called me the next day and
was like
so you know brian says you want to bring
bucky back which is great because that's
what we were going to ask you to do
and i was like this is like this is
insane first off
because i learned more later about this
but like everybody who wrote captain
america must have wanted to bring bucky
back at some point there's so many
fake times he came back like oh it's no
it's the clone from the 50s and he
becomes nomad
yeah nomad like was the one from the 50s
yeah was like the bucky grown up and
come back yeah but they forgot to give
him the vita rays so he went insane
that's what yeah they turned him into
nomad i killed him in my captain america
right because i couldn't have two guys
looking like bucky running around
so in your run who was he he was not
really bucky uh nomad was not
bucky actually he nomad was a guy who
wanted to be bucky and had facial
recognition had fa
had his face changed he was the bucky of
the 50s in the marvel canon
and i had to do like a fill-in issue and
so i just decided to do the death of
nomad because i thought that would be
really shocking
um winter soldier actually kills him in
the comic
um so so joe calls me the next day joe
quesada
uh your artist on daredevil um
calls me the next day after brian did
and
you know it's basically like so what's
you know what's the pitch for bringing
bucky back
and i gave him like the gist of an idea
and he said look
you're gonna have to convince tom brevor
if we can get brevord on board
then you know we'll be able to actually
do this and i just thought this is
insane like this
is a thing everybody has wanted to do
and i have arrived at marvel at the time
when there are people there who are
actually willing to do it because
they've done everything else with
captain america you could possibly do at
this point
and i wanted to do the book more of like
a
espionage thing like 24 was really big
at the time
and i had grown up in a military family
my dad's military intelligence my uncle
was
in the cia and so i've been reading like
james bond and john licorae books
like my whole life and i wanted to try
and take that and bring it to
that kind of superhero thing i was
looking at what like
hitch and miller were doing and like the
ultimates and the widescreen stuff
and i got lucky enough like i asked for
steve epting because i'd seen a bunch of
covers he was doing i think can we get
this guy
because he could make this stuff feel
real and
um so that was working out and then i
just had to pitch tom brevort
on you know here's the story and tom had
a bunch of questions like well how is he
still young
you know and i was like uh they kept him
a suspended animation between missions
like some of it was some of it was like
i had figured that he would be working
for the russians because i wanted him to
be used as like a twisted
thing where he was used against you know
everything he believed so that when he
eventually got his memories back it
would be this
horrible tragedy because you can't take
away the biggest tragedy in captain
america without replacing it
with an equal or larger tragedy which is
that oh my god bucky was out there all
these years and i could have saved him
and bucky hates himself because he would
he was turned into everything he hated
you know he was an enemy to his own
country um
but as i was working on that i was
trying to figure out what what the
code name would be and i just thought
you know russia i started thinking cold
and then i immediately
thought about the thomas paine quote
about the summer soldier and the winter
soldier
and the um the hearings where john kerry
first became famous about vietnam war
the
you know the winter soldier hearings
actually in the early 70s
or late 60s and i just i thought about
those words winter soldier i just saw
that and i'm saying oh that's a perfect
name
for like a russian operative who they're
sending back against america
um and then i just you know i pitched
tom and tom
just loved it and i we started doing it
i was like
know and the pitch was like and i and he
kills the red skull at the end of the
first issue
and we still don't have any idea who he
is we reveal him like at the end of the
first arc
that it's bucky and i remember when that
first issue
that that reveal issue was coming out i
called up tom brevort that morning and i
was like
i think we made a mistake this is going
to be the worst reaction that we ever
are going to get to anything um this is
the end of my career how could you let
me do this
this is like stan lee didn't have the
guts to do this like no
everybody's gonna hate me so much i'm
gonna because because the reaction to
what
steve and i were doing on captain
america at that point was like the
biggest
reaction that anyone had to captain
america since like grunwald was doing it
or
mark wait it was like it really hit big
in a way because it was it was it
touched on a lot of classic captain
america stuff
while sort of feeling a bit more modern
and like a thriller
and eppings are you know i mean that
first double page spread he's like
leaping onto a moving train and throwing
the shield and taking out a helicopter
and catching the shield
and it's just like you feel like you're
in those action moments with them
and you know we just got really lucky
and i thought oh
this is all going to go away now all the
fans are going to [ __ ] hate this
and you know then it was you know i was
[ __ ] wrong as usual and it ended up
being like the biggest hit
it's the most popular marvel character
since deadpool
you know that's like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
like i had no clue
that that was gonna work out i thought
this would be a thing i'd be
i bought a t-shirt that they sold online
to where the convention that year that
said rule number one bucky stays dead
because i wanted to i wanted to
acknowledge that i was like making fun
of myself
because i assumed everyone would hate it
but i wore that shirt and people were
like oh you don't like brubacher's run
and i'm like i'm brubacher
but yeah so it was uh it was you know it
was a blast and i i
just you know the the lack of editorial
interference was amazing like
joe and dan buckley both you know once
the book was a hit it was kind of like
hey leave at alone to do whatever he
wants on this book
and i didn't have to deal with a lot of
the crossover stuff
and i could just the book could be its
own thing and we killed off captain you
guys were just talking about the show
like we killed off captain america
and nobody was captain america for like
over a year in the comic
and then eventually like jeff loeb
called up and he's like shouldn't
someone wear a costume
then there was a big fight should it be
cap should it be uh bucky
or sam and then for me it was like well
i'm telling the bucky book
obviously and it's this is like a path
to his redemption so it makes sense
that it would be him um but yeah i was
like listening to you guys talk about
the thing with the arm and i'm like i
gotta well it's the thing with the arm
because i
i did a thing in uh in the comic where
they take the arm away from him when he
gets arrested by shield
and then the arm gets activated and
beats the [ __ ] out of everybody and
makes its way back to bucky
i i was just having fun with it i'm like
it's like a scene in alien it's like
this weird metal arm skittering down the
hall
it's the hand it's the you guys have
made me want to watch it
now when they first time they introduced
winter soldier in uh
captain america this the captain america
sequel was the captain america two the
winter soldier yeah yeah
captain america the winter soldier did
you know
that they were taking the character into
the movies do you get a heads up as the
character i i did at that point uh it
was so early on and
like when kevin first took over like
when i first met kevin he was like
second in command and there was some
other guy i can't remember his name
who was like when they were doing the
movies through like
uh were they sony or fox or something
through paramount yeah paramount that's
right and and that's when i met kevin
and you know we really hit it off and
you know he was telling me that you know
my
my cap book and this other thing i did
that was about the origin of the marvel
universe like he just really liked the
tone
of what epping and i were doing and so
like i was in
you know pretty regular contact with
them about that stuff then
they didn't tell me in advance i was
told that the after party for the first
movie
that the question now was whether they
do the winter soldier is the second
movie or the third movie they weren't
sure
but they had clearly set it up you know
you could see it in the
in the premiere or in the first movie
when bucky dies and
it's like oh he doesn't die and he got
his arm blasted off
um so i i thought okay it's either going
to be the second or the third movie but
the first movie
wasn't any you know wasn't the biggest
marvel movie
and there was i didn't leaving that
movie and looking at its box office i
was like oh they may never make
you know the sequel and then when they
announced the sequel it was funny i was
it was like the night after the eisners
and i was walking
from the convention to meet some friends
at like one of the hotels like the hyatt
or something and you know that walk it's
like
[ __ ] forever it's like the longest
block in history
and my phone just kept blowing up and oh
i look and i keep saying congrats
congrats congrats i'm like
why does everybody give a [ __ ] about the
eisner awards all of a sudden
and then uh jeff boucher from the la
times was calling for a comment on the
winter soldier movie i'm like
what are you talking about man i just
left the convention floor
and then i was and then i checked online
and i'm like oh everybody's talking
about how the next movie is called
captain america the winter soldier and
i'm like holy [ __ ]
and then uh and then i got an email from
kevin a couple weeks later asking me to
do like cameo in it which was pretty
cool
um i mean cameo in it where's your cameo
i'm in
i'm in one of the redford scenes it's me
and
uh um uh pat healy
are two russian scientists and it's like
the scene where bucky's
in the it's like a bank vault and he's
like strapped down
and he he was like covered in cocoa
butter or something my hands just kept
slipping off of him when i had to
push him down on the thing i love
sebastian he's like amazing
and like an intense actor um but i met
him at the after party and i had already
been a fan from like other stuff and i
when they announced him i was like oh
this is amazing
like he's perfect for it um but yeah i
got
i got to go be in a scene i had dialogue
but it got cut out they
they uh either i did it terribly or they
just didn't need
me yelling in russian
or something like that um but it's great
because i got the
sag royalties from it so i still get sag
residuals from my
because i had like a full week on like i
was there for three days so you have to
get the full week
um so yeah and it was a speaking part i
had to you know i didn't find out until
afterwards
as i'm signing the 4 000 like contracts
that they
make you sign before they put you back
on the shuttle to the hotel
it was it was it was great i wish i had
shaved my beard more
i wish i'd paid more attention to i'm
like a writer i stay at home
i saw the thing and i'm like there's i
made robert redford do
another take accidentally like i there
was this great moment where it's like
redford's in the foreground frank grillo
pat healey
and then there's ed [ __ ] brubacher
the not actor
they're all just they're action figures
on a shelf
they are not moving they are [ __ ]
background
i'm like well i'm a russian scientist so
i'm like
russo walked by he's like everybody
every year great great great ed don't
move your [ __ ] hands
he's like look at what frank's doing and
do that i'm like frank looks like he's
in a sealed
in the mint box action figure pose
like i can't do that like i got ryder
hands man
okay all right so i just didn't move but
there's this great it's like
i for a while was my screen background
it's just like robert redford with like
a blurry me right behind him
and i just thought well that's great
because my last name is brubaker and
most of my life when i've introduced
myself to people
they'd be like oh like the redford movie
which
you are old enough to remember that's
true
did you did you reference that to him
you're like i'm brubacher well i didn't
have uh
i had a oh hi nice to meet you as my
interaction
no they called they wrapped him for the
day and
i never saw a guy i mean he i don't know
how old he was at that point like 82 or
something
he [ __ ] we're in cleveland and he ran
like 200 yards
down the hall and up the stairs to just
get the [ __ ] out
and even especially perhaps at his age
an actor is like when i'm done i'm done
like yeah and he had that like super
famous thing
too going on where he was like reading
the wall street journal the pink section
and like like he wasn't making eye
contact with people
in a way that it's like because if he
made eye contact with people it would
take him
three hours to get to his trailer you
know it's like when you're at comic-con
with like brian pasane or something and
you're like oh i'm never making it to
this dinner
because you're gonna get selfies taken
with seven million people because
you are eight feet tall you were you
were unhidable at comic-con
but um yeah no i i you know i
i i there was a moment where i was like
oh i'm going to tell him this brubaker
story and he'll think it's charming and
then we'll become best friends and i was
like
he's not going to me that he all he
wants to hear about is hey nice to meet
you man
thanks for being in this movie like it's
a job
we have seen four episodes of winter
soldier
um but you have not now what's the story
there
how how do you not check in on your your
kid your baby
it's his own show he's all grown up it's
yeah i know i'm i mean i i probably will
watch it at some point i have a little
bit of a
i'm conflicted about it because like i
knew going in
it was work for hire but also when i
was writing it they didn't have their
own movie studio and weren't owned by
disney
so the idea that this character would go
on to be
a huge franchise where kids would come
trick-or-treating at my house dressed as
him
no and like yeah totally
and like at comic-con like so many
people dressed as the winter soldier
wanting to take selfies with me
he's huge among like the gay community
too like
like women dress up as the winter
soldier a lot it's a
and there's like all this slash fiction
which i used to work on castro street at
a bookstore so
i'm like big on the like back then it
was just kirk and spock
and the occasional salmon frodo right
bucky which they call stucky we live in
a world
where we live in a world where there's
jay and sound bob
version of sci fiction people have
written those stories so i could see
they're being
silent slob
[Laughter]
yeah no and which is for me like one of
the things that i love the most
about having played a part in this
is like this is a character who has
impacted like
pop culture in a major way like there
were
hoodies like when the winter soldier
movie came out there were like
all these kids leaving the theater and
like the hoodies with the bucky arm and
i'm like this is amazing how come i
didn't get a hoodie um
yeah really like where's my exactly
which is part of the problem um but uh
but like i also love that he's part of
counter culture he's like pop culture
and counter culture like that
like who besides fritz the cat or or
like mickey mouse
is like that's that's an even rarer
thing to create
to create a thing or co-create a thing
that has had that much of an impact on
the world and
you know i get so many emails from
people who
that storyline and that character meant
so much to them and i still
like my captain america books still sell
like a ton whenever marvel like reprints
them
and i always get feedback from people
about you know people send me they've
gotten the full
arm tattoo which that's
[ __ ] insane you have bucky's arm
tattooed onto your arm forever
for a lot of the star every i was
changing the star every five issues
because i couldn't
i couldn't figure out what it should be
but um
but yeah so that i feel like really you
know i so i feel a little conflicted
because on the one hand
that's amazing and i never expected that
that would like i said i thought that
would be the end of my career and
instead it's this thing
that has gone on to be a huge phenomenon
um
but at the same time it's like as the
years went on
i started to just think well how we're
not getting anything for this really
like how can we really get like a thanks
to or a credit
but like these movies are making
billions and billions of dollars
and it feels like we just kind of got a
bad deal and i remember sitting there
during the third movie
and knowing how much they like i had
actually turned down
like this tiny little thank you check
because i was like this is an insult
like this is ridiculous um and
it hurt my feet it hurt my feelings
actually which is like
you know like it's just i'm an artist i
write these things and
i was watching that movie and there's
like two-thirds of that movie or like a
third of that movie is a plot line that
i
wrote for a year in my comic book about
bucky training all these other winter
soldiers it was like their b plot
but the whole b plot and a lot of the
emotional arc of the movie
was like stuff that wouldn't exist had i
not written these comics
and i was just sitting there and
everybody who i knew
was in that theater with me and also i
was in the overflow theater by the way
at this movie for some reason
um which that's a that's another one
where you're just like jesus christ like
twist the [ __ ] knife i'm in the
that bird right hand side like
gee put me first row come on like how
bad can it be
so it starts to feel personal in movie
premieres there's the like the big house
where like the writers and directors and
stars go
and then there's the overflow theater
where everybody says invited
but doesn't walk the red carpet gets to
go yeah
that's like the press and like the stars
of agents of shield
yeah it's always the comic book people
who are in the overflow theater it's
kind of funny so
everybody kept coming over to me after
the movie
and going how much did they give you for
this how much so it was like when you
have 100 people asking how much they
give you for this
it starts to eat away at you a little
bit so there's just like
like look i knew what i was getting into
and i'm not unhappy
with my life or that i wrote this thing
like i am super proud of all the work i
did
for on daredevil and cap and i don't
love my x-men run but there were people
who liked it but i loved
i loved working at marvel i had a great
time there
but at the same time i also feel like
you know be a little bit more generous
like
invite us to the after party like steve
epping and i had to text sebastian stan
to get into the after party
at the captain america winter soldier
movie because kevin's assistant didn't
have me on his list even though i was
texting kevin he's like you're on my
list
and the assistant i'm watching let in
like every other assistant in hollywood
and when i finally get into the party
there's all these bloggers and stuff and
i'm like here's steve epping and i
in our tuxedos you know
it's just like inarguably without you
guys
there is no [ __ ] movie it's
so it's weird it's like i'm obviously
i'm complaining about it because i'm
sitting here talking to you guys about
it i feel bad complaining about it
because
so much of what i have in my life came
from writing those comics that
regardless
like if i never make a dime on the
winter soldier i still have one of the
best
lives of any comic book writer in the
history of the medium
i've spent the last like 10 years 15
years
writing things that i own completely
and that i have a wide enough audience
because of
doing stuff like gotham central and
catwoman and
but mainly because of my time on captain
america i wrote captain america for
eight years
and that i developed a huge fan base
during that time
when i launched criminal which was my
first
like fully creator owned book when i had
just finished doing the death of cap
storyline which sold a million copies
and sean phillips my artist had just
done
marvel zombies with robert kirkman which
had sold like half a million copies
so we were at the biggest our name
recognition could ever be
and we launched the least commercial you
know pot we launched a
indie crime comic and it sold so much
that we could continue to do it and that
just felt like a victory
but now it's been 15 16 years we're
still doing these books
and that has just steamrollered into its
own career
to the point now where we're just going
straight to graphic novels and
just in you know and so it's like i have
this whole library that i've been able
to do
and so much of that wouldn't have
existed if not for the winter soldier
so it's like it's a real it's not it's
not cut and dried
right oh look i know hold on let me get
it
you've got it you've got it disappearing
um
yeah like and it's looking at a book
like this
um and reading a book like pulp it feels
very much
inspired by your winter soldier
experiences
so right where here's a here's an old
guy
who had been writing [ __ ] like you
know dime store novel
type stories um westerns that uh
it's worked for hire you know and his
editors kind of treat him like [ __ ]
eventually bring another dude in to
write his stories and
the the sort of the lack of gratitude on
behalf of the establishment for the work
that he had done for years and years and
years
and so he's got to go someplace else to
finally make the money because his wife
will be left with nothing
should he yeah and that a lot of that
well
you know strangely as you say that i
realized like part of that is inspired
by the winter soldier
that and and the one i did before that
bad weekend about the old
the old guy going to the comic
convention to get his lifetime
achievement award where he
basically decks stan lee on stage at the
award ceremony
um it's a stand-in for stan lee
um but that like
like not long after you had your heart
attack
at like where which i feel like woke up
our whole generation in a weird way
like you had a hard time no [ __ ] [ __ ]
if he can
if it could happen to him it could
happen to me oh yeah i'm like hey
i you know i i don't imagine i'm any
healthier than you
i assume less i assume especially now
less you've lost you look you look like
you should
change the name of the show to slender
man or something
that needs taken and it scares children
we do the scouting of children plenty
batman is inviting to children
who what kid doesn't like a fat man
[Laughter]
like like john wayne gacy
but yeah a cup like about two
yeah almost a little over two years ago
i had
i i was i was saved from drowning
and one of the things that was
the hardest like for months after that i
was just going through the trauma of
having
nearly drowned i was in the water for
like half an hour i got sucked out in a
riptide because i was the
guy who had been going out boogie
boarding every day thinking this is the
greatest i'm in the greatest shape of my
life and
then i got sucked out in a riptide so
wait a second we always
hear about people getting sucked out by
rip tides and you're a person
who's not even a casual water enthusiast
if you've got a boogie board that means
you
oh yeah no i i grew up you know and
partly
you know in like gitmo we went in the
water in cuba all the times i moved to
san diego and
grew up near ocean beach and dog beach i
was in the water a lot i was on the
water polo team
but i hadn't swum regularly for 20 years
you know you go to your friends houses
in l.a that have a pool they don't have
a swimming pool they have like a hangout
pool where you'd throw [ __ ] around for
their kids and their dog
so i hadn't gotten like swimming
exercise regularly
and you know boogie boarding is not the
same thing as swimming
it it's fun exercise but you're mostly
just having fun
and i got sucked out it was i should i
knew i shouldn't have gone in that day i
walked down and there were no surfers in
the water
and i thought but the waves looked
really good even closer to the shore
and i just stepped off of a sand bar and
next thing i
knew i was 100 yards out and i i'd never
been
in a riptide so i had no idea that if
i'd just gone another 10 yards out i
would have been out of it the other way
but when you're stuck out to sea
you don't swim further out
but wait what do you what do you mean if
you had gone ten feet i'd only go a
certain
spot that's why the surfers use them as
as like an escalator out to where the
waves get good
you can just jump on in a riptide on a
surfboard and just glide along the top
of the water but in a boogie board
you're half underwater
so i was like treading water and holding
on this boogie board and suddenly i'm
out where the waves are like 12 feet
tall
and i'm trying to figure out i did
everything wrong i knew you're supposed
to swim sideways to get out of it or at
an angle
but by the time i realized i was there i
had been trying to catch waves for 10
minutes to ride one back in which you
can't do
because the water is going two
directions so it looks like this great
wave that you can catch and the next
thing you know it's gone
and you're watching the wave go away and
you're getting more and more exhausted
and i was out there for about a half an
hour my wife was on the beach with the
dog
and she was on the phone with 9-1-1 and
all the cops in town and the
fire people were showing up and i was
like is anybody gonna come out here and
get me
i'm like waving yeah get up oh
someone get a boat they were like two
minutes away from
calling uh from calling over to monterey
uh to have someone come over in a boat
and just grab me and luckily i had a
floatation device
but i was starting to get hit by these
big waves and go under and i was
swallowing salt water and
it was it was the most terrifying like
25 or 30 minutes of my life
and then i just at this moment i just
saw someone coming through the water at
me
and i just thought holy [ __ ] someone's
coming to save me and when they got
there i was like please save me
more like please save me and the guy
just told me
hold on to my he's like hold on the
board as tight as you can
he took the leash and he said i'm going
to pull you out of here you need to just
pedal you need to just paddle
with your feet and i said i got nothing
left man he's like just do it and i just
kicked as hard as i could
and we went and it probably took us
about 10 minutes to get in it was it was
a really bad day there was a reason
surfers went out there
and i got lucky he was like a 18 year
old water polo player who had done like
a couple years of lifeguard training
he saw me he ran down he asked my wife
if i was okay
and uh and she said no he needs help and
he just
[ __ ] took off everything and he had a
little bathing suit on and i'm in a full
wetsuit
the water's like 52 degrees this guy
jumps right into the riptide and he's to
me in like 15 seconds
and he saves my life he drags me in but
i'm out there
for about a half an hour and i'm
thinking this is it and one of the
things i'm thinking is
i'm leaving my wife with nothing like
which like i'm leaving her with debt
really like i mean maybe she'll be able
to sell
my library like you know to hollywood or
to robert kirkman or somebody to you
know make enough money to pay off our
house but it was like
we owed money on this house i you know
had just
finished like a tv project that i'd
spent two years on and was like
exhausted
um uh and and i just thought you know
like we're doing okay
but i was leaving like how was she gonna
survive after that like
there was like how would she how would
she pay off the rest of this house and
and be able to live where she wants to
live and
you know like that was all i thought it
was like i gotta get back
in this can't be it for me and and uh
when i got back to the shore like i
changed everything in my life after that
but i remember one of the things i
thought at the time
and that book really and that thing
really inspired pulp
um was because it's about like an old an
old wild west guy
who you know like lives through into the
like late 30s and sees the whole world
change and then he realizes like i got
nothing to leave to this woman he has a
heart attack
um and he just wants to provide for his
wife so he starts
plotting to become a bad guy again but
all i was thinking at the time was like
i got to be able to provide for
my family like i can't what if i had
just died like
that would have that would have been so
[ __ ] for everybody
me included uh well me the least because
i'd be dead so
the [ __ ] i wouldn't [ __ ] care yeah
but but i and then i thought about that
and i was like you know
that's it's ridiculous that like having
being a co-creator of the winter soldier
that that's like i literally
like that should i should not have to be
worried about providing for my wife
if i die like right now and i don't live
like a high life i'm
you know i'm well off too i do well but
it's like
it's it just it started to just feel
like this is this
this kind of hurts a little bit to be
like
overlooked this way and i know that
they've made deals with other people
that have
had less input on what they do and i
just kind of felt like
it just sucks like i remember sitting in
that movie and just feeling like this
little jack kirby
cancer thing or like ulcer growing in my
stomach of just being like this is what
it felt like kid
except a hundred times worse for me so
[ __ ] you
so it was like so part of me was like
look i knew what i was getting into
everybody everybody goes through this
but at the same time i can't deny that
it's just kind of like it's hard for me
on like a personal level it actually
hurts my feelings a bit
and it's like i said something about it
publicly like a month ago because i was
just
i'd check my public email for my
newsletter there'd be hundreds of people
like some press
fans everybody wanted me to talk about
the show aren't you excited about the
show and i'm like i think i might be the
only person in america
not excited about the show when i see
the ads for the show
it actually makes me feel kind of sick
to my stomach and it reminded me
to hear man isn't it like why would you
want as
as a company why would you want that to
be the way the creators feel
like why wouldn't you want the creator
like when i work with people i try to
give them the best deal possible
and if something ends up being a bigger
thing i'll try to actually adjust their
deal
so that they take part in that too
because it's like i want everybody i
work with to feel like they got a really
good deal
and that they were treated well but like
i saw i see these ads and stuff and i'm
like
this just kind of hurts a little bit and
it made me think about dave chappelle
with like like dave chappelle is the
most successful comedian
arguably of the 21st century maybe even
longer
he's he's definitely a guy who gets paid
like 15 million dollars
by netflix for a single special and yet
when netflix and peacock put up the dave
chappelle show
dave chappelle was like hey you guys
know i don't get anything for this
because i was young and i signed a
stupid contract that's like a standard
contract that every single person who
was doing a show at comedy central
signed that same contract
like he basically was like hey this
sucks for
me and i and i just thought
the whole world had so much sympathy for
this guy
and i just thought like how is it
how is dave chappelle like like comedy
central called him up and they were like
let's fix this
20 years later they didn't have to there
was no legal reason for them to do it
and i was just like that's just a sign
of people realizing like yeah
sometimes people get a shitty deal and
they should get a better one maybe
and it's like there's nothing preventing
anyone at marvel
from looking at like how much the winter
soldier has been used in all this stuff
and calling up me even steve epping and
saying you know what
we're gonna we're gonna try and adjust
you know
the standard thing so that so that you
guys are actually
feel good about this because it's not
like i'm like oh give me all the money
or whatever like i make a good living
and i have like the life i actually want
if i never get a dime
from the winter soldier from them ever
again
like i still have a really great life as
a writer and i will
you know like you know i'm not gonna die
and not provide for my wife like i've
spent a couple years now working my ass
off to make sure that's not gonna happen
but it's just weird to see that that's
coming on and it's like i like
kevin i like the guys who write those
captain america movies i
i love the russo brothers they've done
nothing but great to me
all the marvel studios people james gunn
has had me
like around to like see early cuts of
his movies i love james
like all these people have treated me so
great but at the end of the day i'm like
you know like don't do me favors
you know it's like i'm a professional
writer i wrote this stuff
i work in hollywood i've worked in tv
i've worked in film
i did a [ __ ] tv show with nicholas
refin for two years i know
how hard it is to do this stuff it's a
miracle
that the marvel stuff comes out as good
as it is because
you know how hard it is to make anything
at all
even like vince gilligan has a great
quote like when you're working on a tv
show or a movie
you have no idea whether you're making a
good one or a bad one
and and it's just as hard to make both
you know so i'm always like whatever
kevin has done
and all the people who've worked there
it's a miracle because when i do see
those movies i'm always like these are
these are the best thing you know like a
friend of mine is now working on the
black panther 2 with googler that
started pre-production today i think
and i'm like excited to see that because
coogler i think is a once in a
generation filmmaker
like i met him years ago like before
fruitvale even came out because he's a
real
legit comic nerd and you know like he
was just
like one of the coolest nicest guys i
ever met
and to see him go on to this raging
success is amazing to me
but at the same time i'm like mike i'm
like the only person in america who
like i'll probably watch the winter
soldier next year or the kabul on the
winter shoulder next year and i love
those
anthony maggie's perfect as the falcon
and
but it's just like there's like someone
to
flirts away from me because we all get
to enjoy this
and the one guy who should be enjoying
it the most because he set it in motion
unwittingly isn't getting to enjoy it
like oh that bums me out
it's i mean and that's the thing i don't
want people to think i'm like some sour
because i like i said like i have a
great life and i will watch these things
i watch
the movies but it's just like when you
watch a movie and you start to feel like
i feel like i might be getting ripped
off here like
like it's just this moment of just like
it would
not be hard for it would be an
accounting error for them to actually
compensate creators for what they do
like you know in a way that was even
half as good as you get compensated in
hollywood for this stuff
i like i have made more on sag residuals
than i have made on creating the
character
you know from my one line that got cut
and
uh really yeah and the last time that
they tried to like
make me some kind of a thank you offer
kind of thing which was like
you know i'm never gonna make a living
on thank yous but it was like
it was such a small amount that they
offered that i just
said no i'd rather just have the right
to be angry that i got
that i got a bad deal than take like you
know
what what like a two weeks of salary for
like a writing room assistant
you know like it's just it's just weird
that they're so
ungenerous about it to me and especially
it's weird because a lot of them are
friends of mine
or people who i thought were friends of
mine and i also
know from having worked there that there
is a there is a corporate mentality
where there
like right now someone someone inside
marvel publishing somewhere is
watching this or watching this tomorrow
and laughing that i think i got ripped
off
like there are people who think it's
funny that that
i'm unhappy about it and i know for a
fact because i've watched them
be that way about other people like in
person
and i'm just like there's a sort of you
know and
like i worked really hard on that and
that story meant a lot to me and i look
at those
credits when they come up and there's
all these other executive producers who
are like
people who were just like at the
publishing level who had nothing to do
with
it and i'm like okay so i know how much
that published that ep credit
actually makes you in a tv show at
disney
you know like and i'm looking and i'm
like wow these people have made so much
money
on stuff that steve and i did you know
and it's it's just
you know and i ha now and i work in
hollywood for a living i make most of my
living in hollywood
and you know like i know how how
even a bad hollywood deal is pretty
is pretty good so it's just
you know it's just kind of a bummer it's
like why wouldn't they be more generous
like why would you want ed brubacher to
be the one person who's not excited
about the winter soldier tv show
like can't they ed rude break off a
piece
yes just
it's a piece for everybody but you know
but at the same time like
hearing you guys talk about it that like
that
gave me such a thrill to be like because
first off you're like
i remember when you went from being the
guy who made like
indie films that were influenced by hal
hartley to like oh i'm a full-on [ __ ]
nerd
and now i just tore and talk and i
thought this
is crazy this guy keeps going from the
career we all
thought we wanted in the early 90s to
just doing a bunch of random [ __ ]
but i realized now you were way ahead of
the curve for one thing
but i remember watching one of your
specials where you talked about
directing cop out
and i don't think i ever laughed as hard
for like an
hour when you're telling the bruce
willis story
and i just thought okay this guy is a
legit nerd
and like and he also doesn't give a [ __ ]
about what anyone else says like he's
not mad he's not worried bruce willis is
gonna call him up
afterwards he probably did and
he did but like mistakenly
he butt dialed you he called me up one
day and like it was years later and he
was like hey kev how are you i was like
i'm great man
how are you and we talked for a while
and stuff and he goes i'm gonna come to
l.a soon so i'll come see you and i was
like
that'd be amazing well yeah it's like
fantastic
and then um he never showed up
unfortunately but then a month later two
months later he was like uh
hey i'm gonna send you pictures i found
pictures of you and rose and i thought
he meant
that my daughter's name was rose her
name was harley but i thought he missed
you know he just remembered it as rose
because i couldn't remember imagine who
rose was that i took pictures with he
said i'm gonna send him to you i was
like okay
he sent him to the office in jersey and
then he called me a week later
he was texting me i was getting like a
lot of a lot of calls from this number
and i don't answer my cell phone but
then like the number kept
like it was the same number over and
over again and then finally
he texted me from that number and he
said hey kev it's it's bruce
and i was like bruce he was like bruno
bruce willis i was like holy cow
so i called him and he was like hey did
you
get those pictures and i was like i
they're
at the office in jersey i'm out here in
california but they're going to send
them out here
um thank you for sending him he goes
well i just
this is a little embarrassing but like
those pictures are for another
kevin so he had like
picked a kevin in his phone and he
picked the wrong one
so the calls that we had he thought he
was talking to a different kevin all
together man so i thought like
right now we're putting this behind us
but in reality
he he was never going to call kevin
smith again some other kev who knows
he was happy to speak to but not this
that's the greatest story of all time
costner's waiting for his pictures
exactly he was just like why didn't he
call me
um so for everyone out there because in
chat you got a lot of people who are
like pay ed brood baker as a
as a hashtag and stuff but in a world
where
they can't make disney do something
disney what doesn't want to do
how can they compensate or reward you
where can they get pulp where can they
get all your books oh any comic store
amazon all my yeah i have a bunch of new
books oh thank you mark
i was gonna have them displayed on the
shelf behind me but then i thought even
i can't be quite that douchey
but look yeah i have my new series i'm
doing a new series of graphic novels
uh about a uh
you'd like that i sent you i tell you
the first two uh it's a
it's like uh like rockford meets the
equalizer kind of thing in early 80s la
like a surfer who
you can hire to solve your problems for
you and it's like
the existentialist version of like a um
70s pulp like uh paperback character
like the executioner or somebody like
that
like these lurid kind of uh
montage painted covers that imply
there's gonna be all sorts of sex and
stuff and then you read it and you're
like
that's a fun action mystery that's also
like this sort of existentialist
detective depressing thing
but i do that stuff you know that's what
i mainly make my living on is that and
screenwriting
now um i don't you know and this is
another thing like like i said
i'm so thrilled listening to you guys
talk about the show to the point where
i'm like i should just
i should just watch the show and just
suck up my own because listening to you
guys
talk about it like that's the thing that
that makes me say like it's a
double-edged sword it's like it's not
all one thing or the other
like it's never like i don't want people
to think i just sit around all bitter
about
bucky all the time or whatever i got to
[ __ ] drink
in the name of your autobiography bitter
about bucky
yeah i like that that means so much to
me and the fact that fans actually do
care about this stuff but i also know
there's another part of the fan base
that is like
[ __ ] him he signed a [ __ ] deal and
you know he knew what he was getting
into and like
like whatever that's that's the truth i
did sign a deal and i knew
i knew what i was getting into um
you know that stuff changes over time
you look back at a deal you signed 20
years ago and you're like oh this is
kind of a shitty deal i wish it was a
better one
but i don't at all want other people not
to enjoy the thing
like you know like i i i'm thrilled for
sebastian stan that he's finally getting
more screen time
you know like so i will watch the thing
and enjoy it it's just like i gotta sort
of
prepare myself more mentally for it of
like
all right just understand that there's
some part of you that's going to be like
you know and it's like it's a little
rough but
you know at the same time i almost i
hadn't thought about
any of this stuff until they started
putting out ads for the show for years
you know because i was like all right
well he's been like two minutes of those
avengers movies
like i didn't think about it i went to
see those movies like oh there's winter
soldier
and then you know in the right home i'm
like i wonder if i'm going to get
anything for that
but uh the rest of us like see the
winter soldier were like
i know i'm going to get something out of
that like joy
for episodes yeah exactly and that
that means you know that's
like you know i almost died a couple
years ago like the fact that something i
created and by the way
let me just say the kid that saved my
life
would take no [ __ ] reward
when i went out to buy him coffee like
the next day to like
just try to figure out what i can do for
this kid
like the only thing about my life that
impressed him at all
was the winter soldier fan of all the
marvel movies
so i was like i got saved by a winter
soldier fan
and it's like i learned so much of my
morality
as a kid from reading like captain
america comics or i mean when i was a
kid
captain america was like resigning from
being captain america because of
watergate and stuff
so i'm like age five learning about that
[ __ ] because of captain america like it
affected so much of my morality
and my sense of right and wrong and
justice which is why i think it's odd
that the people who do these things
these publish these comics about the
difference between right and wrong
when it comes to the treatment of
creators overall and it's
not me i'm the least of it you know like
i didn't create [ __ ] wolverine
you know like like bucky existed already
i
created the winter soldier part of it
but you know
jack kirby created bucky and joe simon
like i get that
like but it's weird that these companies
that do these morality
things like they can sit down and just
be like all right well he doesn't get
anything so [ __ ] him
like you know like well like captain
america would
not be okay with that
i think i can speak for him i've never
wrote them for eight years
already on the side embarrassed that
they're that they're so ungenerous about
it
and uh but that's you know they're also
disney you know it's like it's a big
company i mean
everybody thinks walt disney did
everything no one knows who the hell up
iworks is
you know except mark is nodding
yeah i know that dude
um so yeah i mean that's the thing is
like i get to do
you know and winter soldier got me here
on this podcast to talk to you guys
where i get to have mark
like plug my other books for me like
there's not there's no real downside to
it there's just like i wish there were
more upside
i remember running into you at a at a
party i want to say that like
ben abernathy was leaving wild storm and
there was some
like you know oh yeah but like
tony's darts away yeah tony starts away
yeah
and and you know i i was relatively
early into my comics writing career and
i was like lamenting my time at dc
you like listen man honestly just do it
for a little bit
do it and get yourself following it's
like i'm i'm doing better now
after having worked for marvel than i
ever did while i was working for marvel
yeah i think you would just begun the
the criminal stuff yeah
i'm i'm happier now i'm making more
money now like you do your time
you know you do good work you know you
have finance and then you bring that
audience to the stuff that means the
most to you
well and that's the thing too i had a
lot of friends who would come in to work
at marvel or dc and they would
act like they were slumming and i was
like
no dude this is your this is your real
work too like just because you don't own
it like i lied to myself
every every month that i owned daredevil
and and captain america and bucky and
because i was i wanted to invest my full
you know whatever i do into that i
like i hold those up against all the
stuff that i that i did that i own
but yeah it helped build that audience
it helped me figure out how to you know
i wrote
125 issues of captain america if you add
like all of
all the specials and spin-offs and stuff
together
like i learned so much about writing
and you know i mean you know kevin
you've written comics and you've written
movies and tv and stuff
you if you come from comics into
hollywood
you have a pre-compartmentalized brain
in a way as a writer
and people appreciate that a lot like i
remember when i was in the west world
writing room
like i came in as a guy who published
like a thousand things by the time i sat
down in that room
i had no hesitation to pitch ideas to
the point where i actually had to be
pulled aside by the show runner and said
hey maybe let other people pitch in me
now
[Laughter]
but like it's it's such a good training
for for everything and also like i grew
up loving these characters like i
dude me and matt fracture got to make
iron fist cool
like come on he was in ballet slippers
for
40 years
because gil kane didn't know what kung
fu boots looked like
like i got to do all this really cool
stuff and you know it's like i don't
want i
certainly don't want especially on your
show where you guys are just like i
never
whenever i watch your show it's like you
guys love the stuff you're talking about
like i don't want to be the drag who
comes on your show and it's like oh no
the studio
like one of us more than the other ed
let's be clear i love the stuff we're
talking about i don't always like
people part of god that's an excellent
point put that on a [ __ ] shirt mark
i love the [ __ ] we talk about i just
don't always like it
i loved your review i watched the whole
thing before i came on and i loved
watching you guys talk about godzilla
all my questions while watching that
movie i'm like how is
kong standing up on a ship isn't the
whole ship flipping over
how is the ship bigger than the empire
state building and
how can kong climb the empire state
building which he's now taller than
yeah and how do they get kong onto a net
suspended by helicopters
he goes into the center of the earth and
there's like
another world in there and there's a
light
source how is there a light source in
the center of the planet
it's the earth's core mark obviously no
it's just nothing but it's
it's crust on both sides it's like a pie
i love when he just jumps from one side
to the other and then it's like i guess
we're done here and godzilla's gonna
blast a hole through here
and and kong will just jump through it
and then they'll fight some more
i i fell asleep a few times and i kept
waking up and asking my wife why are
they fighting
i don't really know but because it's in
the title
it's in the title um as a writer
you could come up with a zillion reasons
they were fighting my friend
i agree with you though i would take the
45 minute
just all fight cut like why not and
actually like
have some voice over where it's like
round two
or some like attenborough type you know
voice over about like you know this is
what
the planet earth episode
[Laughter]
and then the godzilla runs into the
kingdom
of king the native habitat
it could be charming sometimes too
because sometimes it's not always dire
sometimes it's like look
they want to play you know and stuff
like that yeah
the clown scratches his ass every
morning this is his want
ed you got a website or you got a
twitter and instagram you want to send
anybody to
i am not on any kind of social media i
have a newsletter but i would not
be able to tell you how to find it
because i set it up at some point
and people keep signing up for it
somehow we're up to like
ten thousand people yeah ark's on it
i am on it one of my original
subscribers that's where i get my rubric
news
how else am i going to get it if he's
not any place else to be found email
mark and he will forward it to you
subscribe i am now ed's agent
who does this pro bono yeah i do not uh
i do not miss i only i had i did myspace
and then and then everybody quit myspace
for facebook and i was like oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] i just wasted all this [ __ ] time
on myspace
i never did facebook and then i did
twitter
and then at some point about five years
ago
i just realized how many hours i had
spent looking
at twitter or thinking about a tweet
that i was going to try and make
and i just i wished i could get all
those hours back and spend them reading
books or
comics or going to the movies and so i
just decided to do that instead
and i worried for a minute it would hurt
my career but if anything
it's helped i think when people know
less about you
they are more inclined to just judge
your work in a way
and and not like try to like
hold you to some sort of weird standard
because like
you know you make a joke and 10 years
later people look back at it like james
gone making all i thought all those
jokes were hilarious when he made them
in
in 2004 on twitter you know when they
brought him up again
like 10 years later i'm like oh i guess
pedophilia is maybe not a great thing to
joke about
yeah like this didn't age very well yeah
it seemed funny at the time because
that's the kind of things people were
joking about like i come
i'm you know we're all generation x like
our generation of comedians was like how
offensive can we be
you know so i i will say though when i
first started reading ed brubacher comic
books
i thought you were like 78 years old
like this grizzled pulp veteran like the
name
feels like a like some kind of 1950s
you know [ __ ] dime store novel writer
and then the work is all like super like
just texture and
character and deep like angst and like
oh clearly this is a dude who's been
writing this stuff for a long time i'm
like wait
we're the same age
well i i did start i was writing from
the time i
was like six or seven years old uh
like writing stories i started writing
prime stories as a teenager
they were published by delegates i was a
drug addict and a criminal
um and and it was right what you know
you know like a lot of the stuff that i
started writing about like all the
characters in criminal are based on like
either some facet of me
or some story that happened to a friend
of mine who is dead now and so i can
write about it
um but but yeah so i you know but i i
absorbed
i when my girlfriend was in college when
i was living in berkeley and i would
just go
to mo's books and just buy jim thompson
novels and
david goodas and all the black lizard
stuff and i would just go home and just
absorb all that stuff and
so yeah i just kind of because having
been like uh
x criminal like it really appealed to me
to try to write like sympathetic
criminals
but i do worry a lot about like the
layering of things
and i think because i grew up writing
and drawing my own comics i think about
the language of comics in a different
way than a lot of people do like i worry
a lot about
the rhythm of the page which i almost
never hear people talking about when
they're writing
which is like i worry about how does the
dialogue sound how does the narration
sound with
it how do the visuals feel like they're
a part of the beat
like all of that stuff i i really
agonize and labor over
to the point where you know i'm i'm 40
and look at me
[Laughter]
i was like i said to kevin i'm like you
had a heart attack and you have no gray
facial hair at all
like you haven't you're showing no gray
all you got to do is wear funny hats to
distract
that's it series of funny hats will fix
you right up
um here's a my final question the
[Music]
we we know that there is a batman
series coming to hbo max after the matt
reeves movie
which sounds an awful lot like
gotham central yeah to the point where
deadline even announced it as gotham
central
um which was weird they yeah they've
been circling gotham central for so long
you know gotham was originally supposed
to be gotham central
like i was actually told by people at dc
hey you need to get all your paperwork
in to make sure you're covered
for all the gotham central characters
because in a month they're going to
announce
gotham central as a tv show and then at
the last minute they decided to change
it to gotham
and make it about little kid bruce wayne
for some reason
which is like okay and i
when i worked on westworld we were in
the same building as gotham and so i
would run
into bruno heller in the elevator
sometimes and we would talk
and we went out to lunch and he was like
yeah i really wanted to make gotham
central
and then and then they just said this is
what it is and so this is what it is
and um but i was just like tell me
stories about rome
like rome i know i was a big role man
too
yeah oh man oh yeah i yeah i learned why
rome ended that was amazing i'll tell
you off
offline because there's some fascinating
stuff but i can't i can't talk in public
how was it
i remember that was a pricey show that
to me i was like
when that came out and i and then it
wasn't gotham central
and i was like oh man they're never
gonna make gotham central now but then
they announced this new one
where i was like oh maybe they are going
to make gotham central this time and
rucka is getting like
everything he does made like you know
old guard and he's got this gal gadot
movie
and stump town was like you know a hit
until kovit happened
um and uh like i just thought oh
maybe they're actually gonna make gotham
central this time and then
i reach out to a producer on on that
works for matt reeves
he said no that's not really gotham
central they and they're
they're like making everybody they're
making sure that they don't call it
gotham central
and um it's more of a spin-off from the
movie i guess it's like the james gordon
show from the
it's like a spin-off from their movie
but i got one
i got one thing to say to the [ __ ]
comics industry
not the movie industry that takes from
the comments
i'm gonna paraphrase [ __ ] john
malkovich paid this man he's
[ __ ] money
[Laughter]
farther going out of the way like it's
not gotham central
got the potential it sounds like gotham
central to me
and every time i do it it's not as good
as what gotham central i mean
like i can't you know gotham central
also
another book that just made my career i
can't claim
to i i i didn't even think about it when
i was like
is this really gotham central like oh no
it's a bunch of characters from the
movie
and i was like oh so it's gotham central
but with different made up characters
that matt reeves created instead
and then and then i and i was like well
whatever like
gotham central was such a ripoff of
homicide the book because rucka and i
were both obsessed with david simon's
homicide book
we were being offered a bat a revamp of
batman and the outsiders
and we and we talked and both of us had
no ideas for batman any outsiders we
just wanted to write about the cops in
gotham city
and so we took shrek out to lunch
and we just pitched in the opening scene
where mr freeze
kills the guy's partner and shatters him
into a million pieces and shrek's like
all right we're gonna do that book
and then mike carlin at the time was
insisting we call it gotham murder city
and i was like no and i remember we were
at this meeting and jeanette
kahn showed up which is she was the head
of dc
and she's sitting next to mike who'd
already shot down the name gotham
central about 10 times
and i'm just like such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that i sketched the gotham central logo
with like the badge and the name and i
slide it to jeanette kahn i was like
this is what we want to call the book
and she's like oh this is brilliant and
why are everyone at the table looking at
me like you [ __ ] [ __ ] he went over
everybody's heads together and i was
like yeah but we got to call the book
gotham central
but yeah that was just like rucka and i
just really wanted to write the cops
and they just let us like we called back
we don't want to do this you know we
don't want to do this thing we want to
do this thing
and bendis had just done powers which
was a huge hit and we're like
imagine if powers was about like the mad
hatter and harvey bullock
and the joker like imagine a joker story
from the point of view of the cops
instead and you know the joker in a
[ __ ] interrogation booth like
killing the cop like that was like
so much fun to do and like to the point
where like it was
we but we felt so indebted to david
simon that we created a reporter
character
that's named after him and his wife with
their permission
um ruckel was friends with them from you
know
mystery writing field and stuff and uh
so that's just like you know that was
just such a fun thing to do
i talked to bruce tim a couple years ago
about
and was like trying to push for them to
do an animated gotham central thing
but that kind of goes against the ethos
of what they do a little bit but i was
like you can take that
joker story where he comes to town and
is the sniper
and you know kills the kills the mayor
kills the chief of police like he kills
a bunch of people
you know and you could turn that into
like one of those 80-minute
you know animated things i think that
would be a really awesome way to do
gotham central
but you know i hope that this hbo max
thing just turns out to be called gotham
central and has
you know some of the stuff we're doing
in it that the trailer for that movie
looks really cool actually
like matt reeves is a great filmmaker
there i mean
i like let the right one in but i
actually really like his remake of it
even which is normally like the american
remake of a
of a really cool cheap euro horror film
is not as good
you know and i was like there's a scene
in there that i've seen other people
just steal from over and over again the
car crash scene when it rolls down the
hill that was the first time
anybody had shot something like that
like outside of probably the guys who do
punk i just want them now to re
retitle hbo max gotham central i just
want
the entire channel it's just gotham
central it was i mean that would be
awesome it would sell us a lot of books
and dc
royalties are really nice that's good
so they so there's they like they
treat me i just mean they're publishing
royalties but yeah they they do
well they haven't done anything with any
of my stuff since
paul left like when paul levitz was
running the company when you were there
and stuff
like paul was really generous about that
stuff like even
um with that second batman movie where
they had the scene with the joker in the
interrogation booth and i know from
you know i met chris nolan uh once at a
at a thing
which was the weirdest thing ever have
you ever been in a room when christopher
nolan walks into it
it's like a hush goes through the room
or something
like it was weird i was in the green
room at a thing at this point
why the hush because everyone's like i
can't suddenly
say about tennant like what's yeah
somebody well yeah
this was like this like way this was
before uh
um inception even but i think it was
just that like everyone suddenly was
just like
like because he's he's like kind of a
soft-spoken
shy person in person i think and
i think it was just that thing like when
you encounter someone who's so
famous that you're just awestruck almost
by it like there were other
like i was standing with noel clark from
doctor who
and noel was just like oh that that's
chris for nolan
yeah and he went down the line to be
introduced to people and he was shaking
everyone's hand
and then jeff boucher introduced him to
me and he's like oh and this is ed
brubaker the comic book writer and
chris nolan was like oh oh oh hey nice
to meet you he did the double handshake
and jeff was like that's huge for him
jeff give him some of my uh hardback
criminal collections and my my friend
gabe does
a lot of storyboards for nolan and he
said when they were at the office
downtown he was in
nolan's office talking to him about a
sequence for inception or batman one of
the batman movies or something
and he saw on the shelf of his office
that he had the
criminal hardbacks and i was like that's
the coolest thing in the whole world
i'm done now like i had a friend send
adam mckay a copy of pulp
because i'm like pulp is while it takes
place in the 1930s is so much in line
with all of his own obsessions with the
world right now that i'm like
like i would just love him to read this
i have a friend who works on all of his
movies and so he said to john i'm like
that's the biggest thrill in the world
to know that one of my favorite
filmmakers is going to read a book i did
like that's you know i'm still such a
fanboy on that level like i'll never
lose that i was a comic book nerd
growing up
i mean i got angry at a retcon and
created the winter soldier
so who wrote that nomad miniseries back
in the
in the 90s where he was riding i want to
say fabian
ascenza maybe he was going it was like
lone wolf and cub
yeah it was basically right yeah
yeah that cat must as bitter not bitter
as as uh conflicted as you may feel
about the winter soldier that guy hates
your [ __ ] guts man you took his bucky
out of the equation
yeah there's that no i yeah that's the
other thing is like whenever you have
those jobs too
you know that everybody who used to have
that job is like
especially if you're doing well in it
they're like god damn it
like the greatest thing for me was to go
to these conventions and meet the guys
who i grew up being a fan of
and find out some of them were reading
my books
like marv wolfman meeting mark wolfman
and having him be like oh i really love
what you're doing on you know captain
america or daredevil or
lenween like i kind of became friends
with for a while
um and you know it's just
like dwayne mcduffie came up to me at
one point at a signing
to tell me how much he loved my captain
america run
and and that he thought i was like you
know tops of the field in his and this
was when i
like i would do a signing and five
people would show up and here's
like one of the best writers of you know
the generation and also
one of the guys from the animated you
know stuff that did the best stuff for
them
because honestly like those batman
animated cartoons
brought me back to superhero comics like
when i got offered when shrek was taken
over batman and he's like you want to
write some batman
i was like i got no ideas for batman and
then i went
and went to a friend's house who had a
vhs tape of like
20 episodes of the batman animated show
and those things are so good there's
like and they're also so aimed at adults
and not
children like there's the one of the
episode that really got me was like he
gets dosed by the scarecrow
and he has this horrifying acid
flashback of watching his parents walk
into a tunnel
and the tunnel becomes a gun barrel and
a bullet
shoots out of it and then blood drips
out of the barrel and i was like
holy [ __ ] they can do this i remember
calling up shrek and i'm like can i
write the batman animated comic and he's
like no i want you to write the real
batman comic
but i did eventually get to write one
episode of the or one issue of that one
but uh
but yeah that stuff i still i still rate
that stuff i met glenn murakami
on the street in pasadena he was just
hanging out with jaime hernandez after
they'd had lunch and i saw jaime and i'm
like hey
and then he introduced me and i was like
oh my god glendora
i'm just such a like nerd for that stuff
so
you know it'd be great i got to me that
would be a dream if bruce tim and those
guys would do like a gotham central
animated one even more than
like a tv show because you know tv shows
you know it's crap shoot whether they'll
be any good or
or whether they'll adapt any of the
stuff even you know
if they do that i will cancel my hbo max
and then resubscribe
just so that there's more money in the
pipeline
i'm still logging in through my cable
um ed you uh based on chat
they love you man you spilling the tea
they love your work thanks like i just
bought pulp i just bought criminal a lot
of a lot of stuff
going on oh thanks man that that means
the world to me
and uh yeah i sent you i sent you the
the stuff i got your uh i got your
mailing
of a address of other hardbacks for you
to figure out where to put in your house
oh i already just give to an assistant
i i you know look my movies ain't
working out so well anymore so i go to
ebay all the time to sell [ __ ] people
give me so please send me
as many if you're gonna personally if
you're gonna sign them just don't
personalize them
no no no i've never i'm not unwrapping
them from the plastic kevin i include a
personalized note
uh that i sign but i'm not unwrapping
plan
i'm i'm a man in his 50s now i i
have high blood pressure i don't i fill
out a fedex envelope and that's about it
no i but this has been it's so great for
you guys to have me on and honestly like
i told you
like i reviewed clerks when it came out
at the seattle film fest
years ago get out of here for the stream
i was i was at this
yeah i was like a movie critic first i
got paid 25 to review
clerks that day and uh and it spoke to
me so much coming because i
am x retail i worked comic store jobs i
worked at video store
the video store scene in clerks i still
to this day
that's the most accurate video store
experience of money
i watched that blockbuster documentary
and you're in it the other day and i
thought i was hated blockbuster
like i never actually went to one there
was some lady who came after me on
twitter after that
documentary and she was like look at you
like reminiscing and championing the
same video store that
killed the mom and pop store this
blockbuster killed rst
and like i'm like we i wasn't sitting
there sucking blockbuster's dick as much
as we were reminiscing about the video
store experience
yeah it was couched in this hey this is
the last blockbuster
but man you gotta be [ __ ] carrying a
torch of hate yeah like at this late
stage in the game where you're like lady
blockbuster lost yeah blockbuster lost
big time yeah yeah let's give them their
documentary i always went to the cool
like video like scarecrow video in
seattle
or like the one in the firehouse video
in new york city
yeah exactly yeah kim's video yeah yeah
we'd go there every time we go to a
marvel summit we would always end up
there and i'm buying
which it was great because they always
had next week's dvds on sale early
but i was laughing all the time
i mean but they had to compete but i
loved that experience and working in a
video store like i was
that guy who like the video store job
was the greatest job ever because your
job was four movies
like when you have a regular job you're
checking the minutes you're like
paulie on on the sopranos having to like
saw
you're like it's gotta have been four
hours it's been eight minutes but i
would put on like
four movies that i knew where i would
start with an r rated because no one
came in the first two hours except the
guys were turning porn
um but i like all so so much of clerks
just like spoke to me and i also
at that time i'm like roughly the same
age as you i had the same kind of hal
hartley obsession
and i could see that at the end of the
movie like all that stuff spoke to me so
much so
just to be invited on your guys show is
just such a thrill for me
honestly and and this is a joy
your fans are you know like real legit
like fans of stuff like this isn't uh
you guys don't come out here and just
[ __ ] on stuff except for mark hating all
the people scenes
his reputation precedes him you gotta
have a talk with a man he's got a lot of
stuff
it's what i do man it's just what i do
he's gotta be your siskel
i don't know which one i would be in
that equation because they both picked
on [ __ ] too
they they hated sid and nancy i remember
that i was
more like who's that critic nobody likes
to like you know the movie minute guy or
whatever the [ __ ] who everyone's like
who is that like paul allen or something
like that
i'm the critic that like every studio
loves because like he'll always give you
a quote don't matter what you're making
[ __ ] like
oh yeah i know you tricked me into star
wars movies that i hate
i think now kids he is there's proof
right there
pitch man i went to star wars episode
three so excited
it was gonna be the greatest thing
trilogy is star wars the star wars
holiday special and
empire strikes back and then ewoks
appeared and everything went bad until
the mandalorian
yeah the mandalorian saved the universe
for heaven's sakes
it renewed my faith in star wars right i
gotta say i
am i it is there's an episode of uh how
i met your mother that
defines like how you can tell what age
someone
was when they first encountered star
wars by whether they liked the ewoks or
ate the ewoks
i was in like 11th grade so i was like i
heard there was a
gonna be a planet of wookies at one
point and then they changed it to
teddy bears and i was like i want a
planet of lookies
that first thing was way better an army
of chewbaccas but instead
trump conversions yeah bears all right
well i should let you guys get to
whatever next hour of year
there ain't gonna be a next hour you're
almost the end of our show my friend i
gotta go to sleep and wake up [ __ ]
six in the morning so oh dude yeah we
gotta read like one more ad
you're gonna need some more clothes
cigarettes that's true i will need
another clove
wink wink gentlemen uh give it up for
uh a great writer um a great storyteller
and a great spiller of the t i'm sure
there are a million journalists right
now feverishly
typing about you and the winter soldier
and stuff
my lawyer was like don't say anything
you got it boss yeah you i wrote down a
list of all my recent pop culture
watches for us to discuss
instead of this i would just like to
point out ap
bio if you guys have never watched that
the third season
is existential amazingness the one
that's on peacock the peacock only up
season is levels up of just insanity
uh second season of solar opposites
amazing yeah that couldn't believe how
good it was
yeah okay and the and the documentary
about the go-go's
well worth watching oh is that out now
what was on showtime
it's on streaming i think it might be on
showtime yeah it's just called the
go-go's
but yeah that was amazing the trailer
for it looked really good
yeah oh yeah they were messed up and you
want to hear about it
look at that not only did you get comics
history talk you got some winter soldier
inside dope
ed just gave you some tips three hot
tips on stuff you could be watching
right now you're useful man
thank you well i thought we'd just talk
about a bunch of pop culture i had no
idea it would be so much about me
but it has to be give it up for the
great ed brubacher ed we'll have you
back on very very soon
oh thank you anytime i'm i'm always i'm
always home now
strangely aren't we all indeed
be good ed all right thanks um
holy cats man like
what wonderful like yes wonderful dish
let's be honest but
just great storytelling man i love on
this show when we
deep dive into the actual world of
comics because we you know we always
kind of blow the movies and the tv shows
but the source material for all this
is the books it's always wonderful when
like last when we had kirkman on
these are kirkman brubaker died in the
wool comics
folks who were like you know been in the
trenches for years and years
and now they're seeing their stuff
realized on the big screens and
the small screens and stuff like that
and uh in the case of
of our good friend kirkman becoming
literal billionaires
and in the case of brubacher not so much
right but but also like despite both of
their success
in other media you know like you
mentioning ronan westworld the
the the nicholas wonding riffen show
that he did too old to die young on
amazon
like he's a legit television writer and
creator
but he always comes back to comics i
think that's the thing that we learned
from both of those dudes is that there's
something special about comics
that even once you play in those other
media fields you return back home
and i love that he's doing like you know
his idea of a comic
is not just like hey man it's a he's
captain america and [ __ ]
he's literally doing a comic about like
a surfing fixer
yes you know where it's just like that's
that counts and he's like [ __ ] yeah it
counts man
and he's smart because like somebody out
there is going to be like you know
that's a tv show
[ __ ] bam off it goes and stuff um boy
he was
great mark brought in rue baker so
[ __ ] great catch mark
thank you i was just gonna chime in um
and say you know i know this isn't a
sports
podcast but in sports you sign a seven
year contract when you're 20 years old
and if you throw a hundred touchdowns in
your first
year or hit a hundred home runs or
whatever it is
you get a new contract the next year
it's not like well
you're stuck like they sign you and they
get you
more so in sports it's totally
acceptable
to get paid and renegotiate but in
comics and in writing the writers are
just like well you shouldn't have signed
that contract when you were a kid
which i think is a little uh
not quite fair for creative people but
it's still
in sports that's changed so hopefully
you know
the creative industry will follow suit
soon
yeah i mean sadly work for hire will
always be work for hire
which means like if you go on to write
superman and they make a superman movie
like you don't get a piece of that just
because you wrote superman
um and so like yeah he didn't invent
bucky
and so it's hard for him to to to argue
that he deserves a giant share of
of every winter soldier dollar but
to his point it's disney and they've
made like
6 billion or so either directly off of
that character or in movies featuring
that character and so
the idea that there should be some
semblance of equity
um or at the very least hey man just
break them off a little something
awful piece of that kitkat bar you know
like
happy wife happy life kids like it's not
simple
it's just what do i know i don't run
a giant corporation and stuff but like
you know just
you got you got like
when did he say he created the character
um
man that would have been like early
2000s
i think like and like again we know that
you know of course it's bucky and bucky
pre-existed
you know uh ed um and the winter soldier
but
like he added this dimension and created
this persona
that has been insanely viable so much so
that like there's a whole tv show about
it right now
on disney very expensive tv show i might
add
so yeah it just feels like you know if i
would if i was in charge i'd
break people off just any time i was
doing something with a character
particularly like a character that
somebody who's
alive created in the last like 20 30
years or whatever
i'd be like let's just give him some
loot man like why not like it just
good makes everyone happy like you know
rather than
him out there in the world talking about
like yeah man they don't break off any
money
he'd be out there singing the praises i
shall point out though
that even though you know ed had some
issues with
you know hey man where's my check he's
clearly a big fan
of of everyone involved like
you know name checked feige and and
[ __ ] russo brothers
and our boys marcus and mcfeely and
stuff like that
so it's not like he's sitting around
grousing like i hate all these people
and stuff
he really seems to enjoy and like all
the people involved
so you know i don't know hopefully
i i doubt this show is going to make a
difference but hopefully
somewhere down the road like you know
somebody's like let's open up the books
right you know it does remind me of the
you know when star wars was a hit
um despite the fact that you know mark
hamill and harrison ford
and carrie fisher um didn't have like
great contracts because it was a
smallish movie you know and then and
they didn't have a share of the gross
20th century fox eventually just broke
them off you know knowing full well
we're gonna need them for the sequels
right like it'll be easier for us to
negotiate for two and three
if we just make them feel better about
one and so it didn't have to
but gave them giant checks and like it
just greases the wheels it makes things
easier especially once you're making
money hanover fist
um let's uh take this
opportunity to uh
you know i i mean it's it's 10 53 like
i don't think we're gonna do like uh how
how many news stories you got a few
you know we we we got a few um they wait
till
saturday or sunday when we do this again
some of them might um
let's we gotta talk about our other
sponsor
yeah heaven's sakes they've been waiting
forever uh and then folks
it's the good folks at blue chew we've
been talking about blue chew man
um you know what blue chew is all about
kids this episode is sponsored by blue
chew uh and it's been a hell of a year
personally i feel like i've aged
12 years over the last 12 months and if
you're like me you're feeling your age
more than you used to kids especially in
the boudoir
the bedroom as they say not in france
um it's time to snap out of it kids
spring is here
and it's time to get sprung
with blue chew sprung like that blue
chew you're sitting there going what is
it this sounds like a good deal for me
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable form kids you're chewing
it and it's at a fraction
of the damn cost man blue chews tablets
help men achieve
harder stronger erections mighty
are their erections for heaven's sakes
uh to combat
all forms of erectile dysfunction mark
blue chew is an online prescription
service so no visits to the doctor's
office
no awkward conversations about why your
thing isn't working the way you want it
to be working
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door
in a discreet package process is simple
sign up at bluechew.com consult with one
of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll get your
prescription within days
the best part it's all done online
um now i know some people out there are
like what does this have to do with me
i'm a comic book fan for heaven's sakes
i don't need to know about
erectile dysfunction well i'll tell you
right now this is how you relate to it
ready
you know how our man has to take a pill
and then he gets his power you know how
underdog takes a pill and he gets his
power
this blows it away kids because you
ain't eating no bill you're chewing
you're blue chewing for heaven's sakes
so we got a special
deal for our listeners try bluetooth
free when you use their promo code
fatman at checkout just pay five dollars
in shipping
so that's bluechew.combluechw.com promo
code fatman
to get your first month free and we
thank blue chew for sponsoring
this podcast we thank the good folks of
blue chew for looking out for us here on
fat man beyonce do us a favor
kids if you're out there and you're like
i don't know what the [ __ ] going on
with my boners
give them a goddamn try man blue chew
knows what's going on with your boners
they're gonna give you something to chew
and then life gets better then you're
you're doing the things that you wanna
do with your wiener
uh it's different enough to be hard
unless you wanted to
look at that that's nice thank you
lightning tag lines is your modern day
[ __ ]
draper for heaven's sake uh bluechew.com
ladies and gentlemen go there
check them out they see right there on
the screen man
uh send them your patronage if you're
one of those people that has a
you know a dick uh because they helped
us out
let's help them out in return indeed
um tell you right now the moment that
i'm like it ain't working guess where
i'm going
bluechew.com um okay
let's uh do we do
let's look at a chat like right now sam
gall movie review says news and q a
please don't leave us yet
um let's uh let's let here
you got the news in front of you do the
news stories that like
are immediate and save the ones that can
wait until the weekend for the next show
which is coming up very soon
i assume we'll do this saturday or
sunday of this weekend
so indeed it'll be less than seven days
till the next episode but see if you can
pull anything that's
you know the the one that that really
felt like we needed to talk about it
um this week um because it's already
getting a little bit old
is um we finally got after
what feels like anywhere between
you know nine and 12 months we've been
um
we've been witness to ray fisher's sort
of ongoing
um sort of uh campaign against both
warner brothers
and john sweden and and for
everything that happened with the the
weed and cut
um the of justice league um so and we've
all been wondering like what his
specific allegations were
and uh and this past week he finally
came clean
and he sat down with kim masters at the
hollywood reporter and he gave
his first pastors ladies and gentlemen
wonderful journalists and has been for
years and years and years
um and told his side of the story you
know which which ultimately detailed
um the ways in which he felt um
both emboldened by zack snyder and chris
terrio
to help create um you know a victor
stone
that was going to be the heart and soul
of the movie and that was going to to
help
talk about things like you know what
it's like to be
you know a black man in america he was
invited into the process
because both of them realized that they
were not black men in america and ray
might have
some insight into that and he felt very
good
about the version that fans would
ultimately see in the
in the snyder cut um and then details
the ways in which
joss whedon then sort of detonated all
of that
um from things like inviting the actors
to uh to read his version of the script
and then give their thoughts and of
course by thoughts
he didn't want to hear very much of
anything um you know his
sort of operations on set requiring
um you know him to say lines that he did
not want to say
specifically the fact that cyborg has a
catch phrase you know what the character
does and he felt that felt a little bit
more
um i guess minstrel z than he was hoping
um you know and then basically
just the the the
callousness with which he felt treated
um both in in the creative process and
on the set
um which he sort of was quiet about as
the movie came out because he thought
that's what needed to happen and then
details his
ongoing experiences with warner brothers
in trying to to get an investigation
mounted
that would both bring these things to
light and hopefully change things in the
future for other
um actors and and writers and directors
and people of color
within the business um you know it's
i'm glad he finally told the story um
you know and i think it's it's it's
noble of him that he chased it down for
this long
the and for me like we we had heard
especially in the last you know three or
four months a lot more of the joss
whedon stuff had come out
um and so we were already primed with
maybe he isn't the best dude to work for
um not on the set um not on a staff
um and did not seem to have you know the
best interests
at the very least of ray fisher in his
heart when he was making that movie
um the thing for me that was the most um
uh illuminating was all of the
warner brothers stuff around it the the
way that they sort of conducted the
investigation which didn't feel like it
was with
um sort of full heart and uh they're not
you know clear eyes full hearts uh can't
lose about it
you know the the thing that i think we
all need to realize and we start to
realize that when the metoo movement
began
is that corporate hr departments are not
in the business of investigating
and telling the truth they're in the
business of sort of shielding the
company from litigation
and so like they did not seem to be as
aggressively pursuing the truth as ray
hoped that they would be
because that's not their job um
you know and i think that if anybody
came out of this um
worse off than they went in it's some of
the revelations about jeff johns
yeah he uh he was he trended for two
days on twitter
yeah and not in a not for a positive
thing not for a positive thing i think
the thing that uh that most people dug
into
was that at one point um the star of
bridgeton
reggae jean page um had tested for the
lead of krypto
by the way i don't watch bridgeton but
he was amazing on snl i thought yeah
great like super charming like i haven't
seen bridget neither but like super
charming like
down for anything like handsome as [ __ ]
um
and he was t-tested for the for the role
of segel which ultimately went to
cameron cuff
lovely lovely guy he's a friend and uh
and a top a top man
um but the the reason why
um according to john's was that
um nobody wanted a
black uh superman's god grandfather
um the the creators of the show did like
they were they were down
to cast they were down to be very sort
of openly diverse and inclusive
with it all um but
john's who was overseeing the project
said superman could not have a black
grandfather
um which
yeah i could yeah i mean that's the
thing it's like yeah it could
like like i remember and now i'm picking
fights i i i'm on record you can watch
somewhere on this channel
me uh loving um uh
the uh the the star wars movie
people are like split on ryan's movie
last jedi
last jedi and stuff and i took a lot of
[ __ ] for liking it because some people
didn't like it and whatnot
um but i remember and i think it was a
conversation that you and i had
like you know um the moment where
you know luke can't go to the [ __ ]
salt planet
because his x-wing is in the water
and he's got no r2 unit and so forth and
so on
but you know it's like but sure
but if you really wanted him to do it
like
holding you back like he can magic his
way there
you know like there's a zillion fixes
for that
if you really want to do it you can't
just like rest it on like well
there's the wall i don't know right yeah
i mean according to
uh john's rep um he believed
fans expected the character to look like
young henry cavill
why i don't know i mean they're not even
connected it's not even like this was a
snyder burst show or something like that
no i mean i think that maybe in his mind
the superman of the
era was henry cavill and so if you're
going to look for that character's
grandfather
you expect to see a white dude who looks
like henry cavill
i hate to be this guy but like a
it's [ __ ] outer space on a different
planet where like they don't necessarily
work by the same rules as we do here and
[ __ ] so
you can literally do anything you want
and
me all this [ __ ] i like
spoilers kids all this shit's made up
anyway
so you know the [ __ ] you can do
whatever you want
so like yeah that that that answer
didn't really track
no it's i guarantee you if they were
casting krypton now
and and what's his name how do you say
his name reggae jean-page
and if he comes through the door and
says like i fancy playing
you know [ __ ] superman's grandfather
in a heartbeat
they hire that cat because he's he blew
up from bridgeton and stuff
you know and like he could have blown up
from krypton who knows
um and also like superman's got two sets
of grandparents
so there's nobody saying that the other
set couldn't be
you know white as a white as snow and
like
this set there's a black dude in there
who is also not like the wesley snipes
of black dudes
like he is not the darkest black dude
you've ever seen
he's i'm i'm sorry i have to look around
and see
that that made me feel very what are you
saying
um what is that a is that a is is wesley
snipes a standard of some sort i'm
unaware
wesley snipes is one of the darkest
men to be a legit movie star like
just screen tone wise like nine times
out of ten your romantic leads your
action leads
are gonna be like even eddie murphy was
pretty dark for that
you know time period but like they're
gonna be a little bit more mocha
and less dark chocolate and but reggie's
on page like
that dude sure like 100 i see him having
a white grandson
wesley snipes that's a pretty intense
you know
drop in the bucket if you're counting
that way
look at that we learned some [ __ ]
tonight kid
1106 at fat man after dark
dropping some science since now we're
getting real
well that was joe's really taking off
uh yeah that was so that's what they
went after jeff for
did they go after him for something
about the uh
ray fisher story as well um i mean a
little bit
you know i mean jeff oh yes because he's
i remember he was like
jeff was like don't play it like
frankenstein play it more like quasimodo
like he and he did the hump walk and ray
was like you know
he's he's doing this servile position
thing in front of me
telling me to play him as like a you
know this broken monster and [ __ ] like
that
who everybody likes and stuff and and
you know it was just
kind of tone deaf i guess yeah yeah and
also by the way
like why is anybody but the director
giving
you know even the director replacement
director why is anyone but the director
giving
an actor notes about how to play a part
yeah
i mean it's it all seems like the worst
version of this scenario is what played
out
which is you've got a producer giving
notes to actors circumventing directors
you've got directors replacing other
directors
who don't really have in mind what those
initial actors had in mind for their
characters
you know i i think that
you know jeff jones is an incredibly
talented comic book writer he is
bar and none one of the top ten to kind
of ever do the job
very prolific as well truly like
loves the field loves these characters
loves the field loves the characters you
know
has has catapulted you know has been a
pillar for dc
also the guy who literally put cyborg
into the justice league like
removed martian manhunter and moved
cyborg out of teen titans into the
justice league
yeah you know and so um there there's no
there's no quibbling that that part of
his bona fides
um it just seems that as an executive
perhaps he was in
um out of his depth um or at the very
least
asked to do too many things at the same
time um
all of which might have required a level
of finesse that he wasn't
um prepared to to give um
so yeah i i don't know but at the very
least
now we know the the root cause
of rayfish's campaign um hopefully
change comes on the other side of it
hopefully everybody realizes that
you know there's a better way to handle
this and there was seemed to have been a
better way to handle it
all along um you know and i will also
say that part of me looks at the things
that ray fisher had to deal with
and is like yeah i mean sounds like you
had a bad boss
and honestly we've all had bad bosses
um lots of us have had worse bosses um
there was a there was a chris terrio
piece that came out that uh
that anthony breznikin did it for vanity
fair where he came clean about his
process
working with both zach and how amazing
he thought it was and then
watching what joss ended up doing to his
script and why people hated that movie
and how he understands it and
all that stuff and it's like yeah no
dude for sure this was a bad process
but this is also not the first time a
writer's been [ __ ] over
by hollywood on a movie um where you
know the studio has run rough shot over
somebody's vision
and the other side was not great um this
is not a unique experience
like on either end either as a writer or
as a performer
um so to blow it to make it this cause
celeb
and like this this is as bad as it was
like doesn't sound awesome that's like a
good
time but it also doesn't sound like you
know
racism racism like awful [ __ ]
and you know for anybody who's you know
been in this business for a while
any business for a while i'm sure
they've got worse stories to tell
um but i'm glad that it's all out and
i'm glad that hopefully we can move past
it and i'm hoping that
all the parties involved sort of learned
a bit better or a bit
more how to conduct themselves in ways
that do not require
year-long campaigns and independent hr
investigations
and you know publicist exclamations of
innocence and or lack of guilt
um here in chat ad vexin says
krypton had superman grandpa
dating zod's mom
who was black but the show ripped them
apart
you i i didn't even know that part of
the storyline but i did hear
like last week when that story broke and
a few people in chat
have pointed out that i didn't i didn't
go deep on krypton
uh odd there was a zod grandparent that
was
yeah like michael shannon yeah colin
salmon um the british actor uh of
african descent
um played that character and it's yeah
great
like bringing more you know zods and i
think again that the the writers and
producers of that show were committed
to to sort of diversifying what had been
a very monochrome look at an alien race
um i just think they wanted they wanted
to make it
front and center and it ended up being a
little bit on the on the periphery
um what other news we got
um let's see if we're gonna hit these
bad boys quick
um phoebe waller bridge is joining the
cast of
indiana jones five um
to be directed by james mangold who's
taking over for steven spielberg
she's a good ad is she going to talk to
turn and address the camera
throughout this movie i i hope so i hope
there's a hot priest for her to fawn
over
indiana is off his banana and then back
scene and [ __ ] like that bad version of
like the writing that won her multiple
awards in emmys clearly
i have a feeling she'll just be turning
to the camera
asking what happened to mutt all the
time
didn't you have a son um or
talking about how we should forget
crystal skull
yeah like was it didn't you make another
movie no this is number four
i'm gonna call this i don't think this
is a hot take and i don't think i'm
nostradamus but this movie is gonna be
amazing
mango doesn't miss he's a really
wonderful filmmaker and
he has a treasure that he knows
is a high bar to clear like you're
sequalizing spielberg
yes the only guy who's ever touched that
franchise
um you know aside from young indiana
jones chronicles so
i don't think there's any way he loses
and him casting
her is a really good indicator of that
you know and i also think that
he has to understand the the
responsibility of telling what is
probably going to be
harrison ford's final indiana jones
movie
and so like you know you've gotta you
gotta bring it home
like you're the closer um no pressure
but yeah don't [ __ ] it up
do you think he feels the way about
indiana jones that he did about like han
solo where he's like
i'm doing it once and i'm kill me and
then i'm
done does he feel that same way about
indiana jones or
um i i don't know i mean he seems to
come back for all of them
like no matter what he's like all right
i got the hat and i got the whip i uh
i don't know if the pants still fit but
uh i don't know why suddenly my harrison
ford is obama
i uh i've got the whip i've got my hat
so uh let's go and uh i don't know where
we get this time
is it a crystal skull is it uh
some kind of art uh whatever you want
i'll go get it
let's go um even if they wanted to bring
mutt back and and nobody's crying for
that
it'd be difficult right because it's
shia labeouf it is charlotte
and he's not anybody that anybody wants
to cast right now
uh yeah i don't think anybody's
clamoring for more mutt
yeah so you know how just like in um
temple of doom he didn't mention marion
and in you know last crusade he didn't
reference
[ __ ] billy or whatever her name was
he could just as easily not reference
mutt at
all yep temple of doom
though is a prequel to raiders
so that's why there's no marian
reference true
there's also no marriage in last crusade
there's also what
no marian references in last crusade
well because elsa's running
around with him he doesn't want to talk
about the old fling when the new one
is he's trying to pick up but to be fair
jc i want to correct your correction
even though
temple of doom is a prequel he knew
marion when she was a
kid so i believe when yeah
which is creepy in and of itself and
hope they address
that in the new movie but he knew her
when she was younger
you know when she was like i was a child
i was in love
so he might have known her before he met
uh is her name what was her name billy
no what's her it's a guy's name
in temple of doom elsa schneider is the
character name
that's that's in last crusade uh willie
scott
that's it that's it billy he probably
met marion and had his dalliance with
marian which now that i think about it
when she was like i was a child she was
15 years old
does she say that no but they're the the
story notes
for raiders which there is a document
you can find online which is just the
it's a conversation transcribed between
lucas and spielberg and lawrence kasdan
and they're discussing like basically
the entirety of the story of the movie
and at some point you know lucas was
pushing for marion to be as young as
like 13.
when that but not in the movie but like
in the history
no no like that's was the version of
like when she says i was
young and i was in love he was pushing
debate had a relationship when she was
like 13 years old
and both spielberg and kazan are like no
no you can't do that
and so i think they the the the
compromise
was like she's later in her teens but
still
below the age of consent i mean
what still like they're like compromises
she's young she just ain't that young
we're not creepy
right we're not we're not like really
creepy we're just
like lolita creepy wow man like george
lucas who always comes across as the
most mild-mannered guy in interviews and
stuff like that
like there's that weird story detail
then there's the whole like he's gonna
kiss his sister
weird story detail like yeah but we're
just gonna push past it it's fine
sometimes
kids you need a second draft you
need it you need another person you need
a note
yes get an independent listen to some
damn notes
um what else we got all right we'll do
one more story and then we'll bounce out
of here
um you've heard of stephen king's dollar
babies
yes um yes this is the idea that like
this was a legendary uh for film school
students uh i even knew about this when
we
uh at the vancouver film school the
school for which i'm now
a creative ambassador thank you very
much vfs.com
in any event free ad from my friends in
vancouver film school
who taught me how to make clerks take
that for what it's worth
uh my preamble was so long i forgot what
we were talking about what was that
stephen king's dollar babies
thank you even in film school uh
neophyte filmmaker like myself
heard of this because this goes back
long time ago like not a recent thing
goes back to like the late 80s early 90s
a bunch of film school kids started
writing steven uh king going like hey
man can i adapt a story for this
it's just for my school like please and
so he came up with this
brilliant and very generous system where
anybody
can option a stephen king
thing to shoot for one dollar
yes but the moment it became like
profitable if you
sold it or something like that then it's
a different discussion but if you were
just making it for the
academic pursuit of i'm trying to tell
the story may i use your story to make a
movie to see if i
know how to make a movie he very
generously was like yeah for the price
low low price of one buck i'll give you
the rights to make a film school version
or something of my material indeed
um and so it's been a thing happening
for decades and lots of filmmakers have
gotten missed i mean i think
even um when we're losing his name now
um sharashan redemption guy uh frank
derek
frank darabont um got his start like
making a dollar baby
um anytime i'm sorry i got to cut you
off anytime someone says frank darabont
in this world
i light a clove cigarette so go ahead
i'ma clove it up
um so so now there is
uh on the heels of this sort of
initiative going on for years
um a stephen king rules dollar baby film
festival
which is a free virtual event where
attendees can watch
upwards of 25 of these dollar babies
um from april 23rd to april 25th
if you go to um barker street cinema dot
ca um it's run by a couple of uh very
nice canadians
um a fella named james douglas and norm
coyne
who also runs the northern fan con
convention that's brought both
kevin and i up to do uh to do a fat man
in prince george
um canada um they're the ones who are
organizing it all
and so if you go to that barker street
cinema dot ca
um all the information is there you can
go on vimeo or youtube and watch all of
these movies
starting from april 23rd to 25th um
and i think like [ __ ] it like as as a
dude who is embarking on making a short
it is always good to see um places where
people can watch
things like this um won't cost you a
dime
um so they don't have to give stephen
king more than his dollar and
frankly he doesn't need it um but just
to see various interpretations of
stephen king works from people who just
love this stuff
it must be thrilling for him too now to
be able to like put it all together and
be like look at all of them
look at all i mean he's seen many
interpretations of his work over the
years sometimes he
hates the interpretation or not into it
but like you know gifting these stories
into the hands of budding filmmakers or
budding storytellers
you're getting a passionate storyteller
taking on that material so i would
imagine like it must feel
i don't think he you know can ed
brubrecker it where he's like i'm not
going to watch that
you know like he's he's got to be like
i'm like those are my kids i want to see
how they did
what they did man i want to see like
what their version of
randall flag looks like or i want to see
how they adapted apt people in a
different way
or any of the different seasons like
short stories and stuff so
yeah that's that's good for him this
[ __ ] is like so
influential like think about it stephen
king
feels like he's been around since i've
been like born but he
started like kind of like while i was
alive
game like a cultural phenomenon
like in the late 70s i want to say earl
late 70s early 80s
so he's been for lack of a better
description i mean other than prolific
famous one of the world's most famous
writers of our lifetimes and stuff
um for as long as you know i've i've
been cognizant
of pop culture and to be this guy who's
like written
so much material that you're like yeah
if you want to adapt one of my many
[ __ ] things
you know send me a buck and we're good
yeah is that a form
make it all legal nicey nice go off and
do a thing
like if you sell it then you know
there's there's
more contracts and more negotiations to
be had because
it's a it's a marketplace and i want
what's a value but i'm never gonna
i'm never gonna stop a guy's dream you
know like and i i always appreciated
that i
i remember talking to uh to lin-manuel
miranda i interviewed him once
and i asked him about high school
productions of stuff like you know in
the heights in hamilton
and he's like i am never gonna stand in
the way of a kid who wants to make
something he's like so if you have you
got a song in your heart and what you
want to do is get a bunch of friends
together and do a
you know do a local production of this
i'm never going to get in the way kids
should be allowed to be able to do this
stuff
you know and and i don't care who's in
it you know it doesn't bother me
whatsoever because like if you're a
legit theater company and you're
mounting this stuff you cast the [ __ ]
right like
hamilton is the way hamilton is because
and it is what it is because of
the intentional way we went about
casting those roles but if you're like
a 15 year old kid with a bunch of
friends who just wants to put on
something to raise money for a car wash
or whatever
go to town like i'm not going to be the
dude to stand in the way so for stephen
king to also say
yeah no i can sell this to united
artists tomorrow for you know 200 grand
and then you know a million dollars if
they make a movie or give it to this kid
for a dollar
and maybe this kid will grow up to
become frank darabon and then
ultimately make the best versions of my
stuff and if not
then a kid like indulged his dream to
make a movie
a stephen king movie of his very own
um i bet you the way to his heart
would be if you were like dear mr king i
would like to sequalize the lonesome
death of jordy verrill
and i want you to play the son you never
knew that your character had
and so he gets the second bite at the
apple to play his creep show
[Laughter]
because i'm sure he's watched it for
years now and been like
i could have done that part better i i
might have
you know instead of like he might have
chosen a different delivery for
all meteor [ __ ]
he's got many years to look at that
performance i'm sure he would like to
modulate it you know
it's just a thought who knows and just
you know maybe who can tell
um good for him man uh good for him
so
barker street cinema dot ca wow
go go take part kids freak don't cost
nothing
um we uh we it's now the show has hit
the
three hour mark kids yep
um the uh normally we would go in the q
a but like i
i gotta go because i got i gotta be on a
set very early tomorrow morning
i gotta go to sleep but should we do at
least one question
whatever you feel my friend jc bam in
here and join us
okay i have i have some good questions
do we want
you got to pick the best oh man uh yeah
my friend
now to be fair we wouldn't know what the
best is so
you could pick anyone and we'd be like
ooh that's good it could be
like that was the best all right so
we've had a
pretty crazy
serious issue based show so let's do
something silly for q
a uh sir tino wants to know if you had
to make a porn with any marvel universe
character
who would it be and what would the
climax of the story be like
this feels like one of those questions
gonna get us into trouble
well okay make it a porno
uh uh reed and sue richards
read for the obvious reasons
it just keeps stretching it just keeps
going
um and sue because
you can't see her so it would not be
objectifying a woman in pornography
okay so then what's the climax
he comes mark that's how that
ends i don't know if you know this or
not
but that's the hot part because since
she's invisible
you see it inside like you see
him just like bust a nut in the air that
instead of hitting the ground
just floats in the air what is that well
jesus johnny those are fallopian tubes
yeah then he could
give people you know medicine
downstairs and he's like i thought i was
rock hard
jc ladies and gentlemen yeah you see
bamfing
in with a closer like that and then
bamfing out like he's [ __ ] george
costanza like
i'm i'm done goodnight here yeah i
thought i was rockhorn
all right mark who are your who are you
putting in the porn who are you
in the prawns you know i sort of feel
like there's
if it hasn't happened already there
probably needs to be
you know a spider-man gwen stacy mj
um whip the whip there's just [ __ ]
white [ __ ] flying everywhere
um and also and also they do it upside
down right
a lot of upset bouncing and swinging
and green screening and like what's on
those windows the spider-man in town
again i just
jizz it all over [ __ ] madison avenue
that that's where i go i go i go then i
go the blonde and the brunette and the
web slinger
they gotta they gotta start slow though
man they're in college these
these kids right they're all in empire
state university yeah
and uh you know she's gotta be like
uh you can't go right to the sex mark
you gotta you gotta remember these
characters they were written in the 60s
and [ __ ] like that so there was a you
know
so you got to go up the petting ladder
so that way we get the scene
where mary jane says to spider-man as
she
you know gives him his first hand job
peter parker mind you not
we'll have a separate story line with
spider-man and stuff but the line would
be like
face it tiger you hit the jerk pot
i'm sorry i know that was a world of
setup a lot of shoe leather
to get to where we're going on that joke
but i think
the destination might have been worth it
yeah see i would have gone like
you know the the you know peter's in
college [ __ ] super nerd
um and then you know the climactic scene
is the three-way between peter and mary
jane and gwen stacy
and then it's the she knocks on the door
it's like face attacking through the
jackpot and then gwen stacy walks in and
then it's like
everybody's getting it on
and then of course you get your
spider-man black cat stuff because you
got to get some black cat in there too
because you know this costume has got to
be coming off
but then but it's parents weekend at
college
and so they have to keep it hidden from
aunt may
well there's your scene where aunt may
is [ __ ] somebody
norman osborne yep
i like it and then peter comes to the
conclusion
in the third act if you've even made it
that far
third act it's one is 40 minutes long
third act peter comes to conclusion with
great penis
comes great responsibility
that's the name of the movie peter comes
to a conclusion
no the name of the movie is peter tingle
um all right that was pretty good uh you
know what let's do another question
while we're here
okay just go home on that it was such a
great game
ender but now i'm having a good time i'm
like let's hear another one i know i
love kids like listen all right we're
not doing
just one news story uh what more news do
you got i will do all that
do you have any more porno questions
jason that really brought me to life
we'll do one question that's [ __ ]
let's all do all three questions
um i got a i got a weed weed question
um sam gall movie reviews
wanted to know what comic book
characters life would improve by smoking
weed
and what character's life would totally
fall apart if they smoked weed
so if it was popeye and
he eats spinach that's what character
would have
weed as his spinach
that's not the way i read that question
i don't think you need to bring
popeye in as a nation
um what here is what
what hero would be would benefit from
weed correct
correct and then what hero would be
diminished by weed i would say
batman would definitely [ __ ] benefit
from some weed man like just
you know like my parents are dead but
you know what all parents died don't
they
you know yeah
it's what they did with their lives when
they were here and what they did was me
and i'm beautiful
um he would benefit from weed who would
fall apart from weed
you you mark you do who would benefit
while i think of my who would fall apart
um i my first instinct was doctor
strange
except i'm 100 sure he's already smoking
weed
like there's no way he's not astral
projecting thanks to the addition
of some cannabis into his system um
so then i go daredevil like i feel like
pain management
is a is a good reason for that dude to
just like listen
all right i know all of this hurts all
of it hurts i'm just a [ __ ] dude who
can maybe see some
[ __ ] without seeing some [ __ ] um
i'd like to smoke that away if that's
all right
i gotta be i can't i can't get drunk i
can't get high on like pills and [ __ ]
i gotta do natural because i gotta be on
the go
so yeah i'm going uh i'm going daredevil
uh you know who shouldn't smoke weed
professor x
guy he's got too many too much access to
too many minds so if he gets a harsh
buzz
if something harshes his mellow we're
all
[ __ ] especially if he's wearing
cerebro
bro cerebral syria
he's like i'm gonna put on cerebro
and then he's just like what am i doing
wrong why am i what the [ __ ]
and then we all feel his bummer
uh i i go i go the flash
i feel like the flash is not a dude that
you want to slow down
with you know and i i you he just
he needs to be a little earned on edge
he needs to be a little bit bouncy and
poppy
and yeah you can't you can't mellow that
dude out otherwise it's like
what's the [ __ ] rush man like
why although now i desperately want to
see like chong
as the flash hey man
they're not here man
um barry's not here
the uh bonus uh for extra credit
i would say aquaman and or submariner
because you can't light a joint in the
ocean
in the ocean on the surface you might be
able to but down below man they'd be
sitting there like
damn it you know so i would ruin their
day to say the very least
very fun question all right we got to
get a third one and we're so close
as well i had uh hakai gonzalez
in chat said green lantern would not be
good on weed
hey let me tell you something having
seen like every green lantern cartoon
growing up
all he ever did was a giant race car or
a giant baseball mix
he would have benefited from some
[ __ ] weed like let's be honest
hal jordan is a test pilot which is
great and very brave but like
they're not known to be the most
creative people in the world
like yeah maybe creative in how they
maneuver a plane but it's not like
hal jordan wrote children's books for
years we have this
massive imagination or anything it's
always like i don't know a giant
baseball mitt
world's most powerful [ __ ] weapon
fired by imagination
and it's a series of giant baseball
mitts and [ __ ] race cars so i
for one would appreciate a stoner green
lantern who'd be like
giant vagina with tentacles man hr
geiger stuff
did they ever do like some 60s set green
lantern
uh issue where he dropped acid and then
like
suddenly it's the [ __ ] like yellow
submarine just all up in the [ __ ] but
green
i think i think uh they haven't yet but
i think
you just pitched it
sounds like grant morrison would be uh
would be a great writer for that yes
well don't steal his sunshine mark
bernardin can be a great writer for that
although i'm giving it to graham
morrison he doesn't get all the weird
stories
i can do weird i say when i say who
there's your there's there's another
shirt for your [ __ ] t-shirt store
i can do weird i can do weird all by
myself
um all right what's the third um
let's see do you want to do a silly one
or a
more serious one oh and that's not too
serious that's the only
show peyton sent him home and a bummer
man
pedro luna earlier very start of the
show
asked a question um about the super
soldier serum
that i had misread as
if you could give the super soldier
serum to anyone from
cheers who would it be
wait how did you misread that what was
the mystery it said if you could give it
to
anyone in real life
who would it be cheers but the chat was
scrolling so quick so i thought it said
if you could give it to anyone from
cheers and you know what
you get co-writing credit on that
question because that
is a much better question i liked that
one better
anyone from cheers let's [ __ ] do this
kids we're legit
gonna try to figure out which one of the
cheers cast
and yes it is the year 2021 we're gonna
try to figure out
which one of the cheers casts would be
uh
benefit from the super soldier serum uh
call your parents and tell them we're
talking about
okay going through the whole bar because
it was boston
sam malone does not need the super
soldier serum no he's already a pitcher
he was there he's got it all uh
uh diane
chambers does not need the super soldier
serum she's a brain right rebecca
is a mess don't ever give her the super
soldiers
[Laughter]
i already know who my pick is i need to
and i think we just
i bet you let's say at the same time
count three ready
one
it just all it does is make what's there
bigger it accentuates what's there so
all you get out of a super soldier serum
with cliff
is endless [ __ ] stories and factoids
how is that a bad thing they're
weaponized mark
it may it may save the us postal service
though if cliff gets it
he could deliver all of boston's cliff
is a man who operates his life by a code
neither rain nor sleet nor dead of night
will stay that messenger in his
appointed tasks
that [ __ ] becomes the super
soldier of male delivery people
you guys are out of your minds it's
[ __ ] woody bro
woody this simple reason the super
soldier serum
it's not about being a good soldier but
a good
man and woody is a good man
clueless but good pure of heart
i mean you're not gonna give it to to uh
you know [ __ ] norm
although i'm sure vera would have
appreciated that indeed
you're not gonna give it to carla for
heaven's sakes her mouth is her weapon
she doesn't need anything more than that
uh frasier he's already had it he's the
beast
you're a good point good boy we've been
down that road
we have so yeah i i'm i'm giving it to
woody
i don't know why well we left out coach
too
ah see now coach yeah coach is like give
it to me maybe you saved my life and
woody doesn't even come on the [ __ ]
show
i think i think coach is the best man on
that show
you know what you're right he's got a
pure heart but woody was just as pure of
heart so woody could be as bucky
but coach coach gets the super soldiers
here
good to be robin colcort i go to studio
girlfriend woody
[ __ ] cut um
wow um or one of the tortelli's for
heaven's sake there you go
all we know wow but kids you just
listened to two guys who know
remember way too much about an old ass
[ __ ] tv show
and we didn't discuss lilith lilith
could have uh could have earned it
you're absolutely right lilith for
heaven's sakes she's a saint
i mean honestly lilith you try to give
her the super soldier serum
needle breaks in her skin indeed
she's just squirrel yeah you know what
that leaves little freddy
maybe give it to frazier and lilith's
kid freddy
because some people would question the
wisdom about giving like a 78 year old
man the super soldier suit
they might they're like look
he's it accentuates your strength don't
get us wrong but
it's accentuating the strength and speed
of a 78 year old man
which means when he goes real fast he's
walking about as normal as we walk
pretty much and the jowls nobody needs
that much jowl action
unless you could weaponize them
um that was a good question we answered
three questions we
did booze we had a guest we did chit
chat we had sponsors
we had a full show we did i didn't think
we'd get there but lo
three hours and 25 minutes later
it took us a long time to get to that
full show but turns out
you can do anything in three hours
except watch the snyder cut
true um yes my wife just literally came
to say good night
clearly i'm like oh my god it's 11 43.
she said good night mark good night jan
um
that is a packed [ __ ] show kids boy
that's a lot of show did you come here
did you get your money's worth
hell yeah you did because you paid
nothing and we gave you so much show
do you remember all the [ __ ] tea
that ed brubaker spilled oh my god
oh my god i just i was you know how much
it takes to cut me off and make me shut
up and i was just like
dude this felt like an old school
kevin smith q a where somebody asks you
one question
and then an hour later another person
asks another question
and then two hours later everybody goes
home
and andy layass music wrote one more
hour
[ __ ] no dude you gotta we gotta
we gotta go man i'm gonna be standing on
a set tomorrow [ __ ] seven in the
morning and be like
no you don't understand we were we were
talking about which
member of cheers deserves the
superstition
what do you guys think
um we uh have had a great time kids and
uh we had two great sponsors please
go patronize the good folks at blue chew
and go patronize
the good folks at native
bluechew.comnativedeo.com uh we thank
jc uh for hosting us here in the unreal
world
soon he'll be hosting us again in the
real world how was your uh
opening your opening body really good
really good all week
really good all week i was surprised
people are people are ready to go back
out
and what's the deal people coming into
masks they wear masks then take it down
take a drink put the mask
on yeah if they're seated and eating
there they can have it off
right the [ __ ] on there it is man uh so
soon
me and mark will be back in the bar
doing the show in front of people
no that out masks
at least us you [ __ ] will need masks
yeah everyone's wearing a goddamn mask
don't leave behind three spit guards
you won't even be able to see us it'll
be so deep
the plastic in front of us you'll be
like is that them
yeah it'll be like inside of an aquarium
like why is there
nine inches of plexiglass well
transparent aluminum
because we're going back to the life
kids
the chance of catching [ __ ] um
get your vaccinations do it they're
opening up the whole goddamn state out
here in california i don't know about
the rest of the country but
but for california for those of you who
are like i'd like to go to fat man
beyond
live at the scum and villainy cantina
right on hollywood boulevard in
hollywood california
uh you can join us there man like
without fear
yeah um uh we have no show ladies and
gentlemen
uh without uh the news gatherer
storyteller
uh who's always somewhere that i can
never figure out the direction
that's wrong that would be where it is
so let me replace that so i go like that
now that's stupid that
there you go look at him
look at him i feel like we're at the end
of like a burton reynolds dumb eloise
movie
where it's just what are they doing
credits are rolling and they're just
like crack
honestly i i like though those outtakes
were i think the first outtakes i ever
saw in my life and stuff they
popularized that form
and um bloopers if you will but um that
was like one of the reasons i fell in
love with movies and wanted to
like eventually make movies because i
was like that looks
fun everyone has fun when they're making
movies all they do is laugh and crack
each other up like what a great job that
would be
no i i i [ __ ] i'm glad
that we're coming across like burt and
[ __ ] dom i just want to know which
one i
am uh clearly you're a bert no
you've got the facial hair for it i do
don't i you and i'm wearing a hat like
the bandit
[Music]
just like holding the band
um there it is ladies and gentlemen give
it up for the man who brought you the
show mr mark bernard the guy
my pleasure there it is and uh that
ladies and gentlemen is fat man beyond
for this week we will be back
in less than a week saturday or sunday
we'll let you know which
which uh one it is man i felt so bad
because i didn't put up
nate uh gonzalez does our artwork all
the time
and you know it's
beloved the audience loves it they buy
the shirts and stuff like that
um nate gave us this amazing like lethal
weapon piece for this week
and i didn't put it up until like we
were about to go on the show because i
was
shooting a thing today so um big thanks
to dark nate returns for that for
heaven's sake always
um all right kids that
is fat man beyond for this week um i'm
kevin smith
i am mark bernhardt you tune in next
time
same that time same fat channels
modcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith for a very long
show jeff's kid
you